une production du studio sfr nous sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut que nos invités date je peux donc
pas le haut
aujourd'hui au podcast on a reçu mélanie
maynard que vous connaissez animatrice à
la radio à la télévision et idole de
jeunesse parce qu'il était dans son camp
près de chez vous qui était une émission
culte pour nuit pour bien des gens au
québec et est ce juste avant vous en
dira un peu plus on va les remercier nos
sponsors sans qui rien de tout ça serait
passé
on les remercie le batka d'aujourd'hui
est présenté par wonder rabbis yeux la
meilleure nourriture pour votre shield
et produit innovant des produits
hypoallergène éco-responsable alors fait
le dans le plus grand respect de
l'écologie fait à partir de protéine
alternative et tout se fait au québec
par des jeunes québécois des jeunes
d'ici parce raku perche par mois en plus
s en fait new york plusieurs produits
innovants dont des gâteries fait à base
de grillons des gâteries pour votre
chien vegan fait à base d'algues de
gaspésie et de pulpe recyclé de fruits
travail trabaud ration que la compagnie
look qui vont des jus --qui par les
peuls qui font des gâteries pour vos
chiens avec ceux des prix de la
nourriture à base d'insectes et de la
nourriture à base de poissons durables
qui sont pêchés en fait parce que les
poissons ils nuisent à l'écosystème
marin donc ils doivent être pêchées
travaille avec des pêcheurs nord
américains qui luttent contre la
dégradation des fonds marins donc votre
chien va aimer ça c'est tout ce qu'on
que le saumon c'est plus protéines et
que le boeuf donc vaches chèvres capoter
tout en sauvant le monde on a
un code promo un code promo qui étudié
20 alors vous avez 20 % de rabais sur
tous les produits sur leur site internet
mon chien selon le monde point ca y est
allé voir sauf merci lagarde puis à vos
chiens vont apprécier notre sol merci
sous vêtements qu'elle le podcast
d'aujourd'hui est présenté par alta
science qui est une entreprise de
recherche contractuelle spécialisée dans
les essais cliniques a été fondée en 9
ici au québec lors le coup sont à
montréal puisqu'ils font en fait ce qui
soutiennent la commercialisation de
médicaments génériques donc des copies
ou des versions moins chères mais tout
aussi efficace des médicaments que vous
connaissez bien qu'ils sont déjà sur le
marché
il participe aussi à mettre sur le
marché des nouveaux médicaments
on sait la recherche en science la
recherche clinique c'est super important
ce n'état veut essentiel en fait au
développement de nouveaux médicaments
puis ces médicaments d'après ce qu'on en
a besoin et donc c'est important de
participer et de soutenir la recherche
comment ça fonctionne en fait vous allez
aller sur leur site web où les appeler
pour l'éventail de tests qui sont
proposés vous choisissez celui qui
conforme à vos intérêts et si vous
répondez aux critères d'admissibilité
vous allez être choisi pour aller passer
un séjour en clinique ou est ce que vous
allez faire les tests cliniques vous
avez les repas gratuits
vous avez un dortoir vous avez
l'internet vous avez
la télé hd mieux mieux de mon appart
enfants à verden et il ya une
indemnisation monétaire 2009 à 9000
dollars par don tout dépendant de
l'étude que vous choisissez pour avoir
plus d'informations dirigez-vous au
triple w points gault alta point ca ou
appelez au 54 3 8 052 2 0 merci la gagne
d'alto science des commandites et
podcasts et inspecte comment vous vous
disait cette semaine on leur soumet
l'animé non moi c'était un rat est venue
la recevoir parce que pétrolia quelques
musiciens l'un tantôt d'un pétrolier moi
c'est non c'est mon premier coup de
coeur le 15 mai découvrez qui c'était
une idole féminin à l'écran booster
budget spears mais chacun son idole cas
qui se découvre et m la mienne à voulait
sauver l'humanité c'était tellement le
fun est tellement cool c'est vraiment
drôle et tellement spontanée est
tellement détient triangle décision de
ses bons mots et les sans filtre
j'aurais vraiment une vraie de vraie
sans filtre tout ce qui lui passe par la
tête on a parlé de tellement de choses
on ne parlait de parler de sexualité
on a parlé de dunks près de chez vous
bien sûr comment c'était l'ambiance la
gamme des cégeps qui tournait c'est
l'ambiance comme des cgv
on a parlé de ses enfants on peut parler
des aigles de son fils qui veut une
carrière et veut se lancer dans le rap
allé à los angeles gomen gaudou et
cherche des indices mais il ya là un
côté rebelle que j'adore c'est un espèce
de je m'en foutisme de faire ce que je
veux
quand je veux de prendre des projets qui
m'intéressent pi2 alors pas peur de se
lancer envie de poursuivre ses intérêts
puis quand ça pète son affaire de
quitter en fait mme anissa le du succès
ça je trouve fascinant est vrai est
vraiment vrai c'est inspirant que vous
allez toujours ça dans l'épisode est
assise à eux les sites amazon les
commentaires l'aïe qui souhaitait
aborder chrome savez c'est quoi c'est
quand ça marche fait que mon podcast
bonne écoute
c'est parti c'est parti s'y colle merci
ça me fait tellement plaisir en ce jour
de tempête
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ici mais que
nous autres on préférait le faire quand
même
oui ça on se déplace on ne compte pas le
choix parce que j'ai regardé et on l'a
racheté le studio ici on loue après mon
pied il n'y avait plus petits pas c'est
jusqu'au 3 marchant
oui c'est comme est ce qu'on pourrait
tout se dit qu'il ya trop de podcasts
conclusion quand il ya beaucoup c'est
fouet au trot veulent adresser tout de
suite je me suis dit que si je m'en veux
dire là encore un autre podcast mais
tout en a fait qu on met deux à vingt
ici non ici je sais mais je donne ça en
attendant j'en ai fait deux trois quatre
ouais mais si je vous ai une vie c'est
l'ombre c'est toujours la rencontre
lotois je ne savais pas que j'avais un
couple lance macklin chose est très fine
de couche j'avais pas été deux paquets
qu'est-ce que je ne consomme pas de pas
de carton mais j'en fais beaucoup on
s'est un peu comme la tdg jamais
consommé la td non plus parler fait
beaucoup même une zone oui comment ça
c'est peut-être couleurs mais on ne
pourrait pas la question tu pourrais
vous connaissez de où on se connaît
depuis la 5e année du primaire
depuis prime un point fait de la
natation à 100 mhz à québec et on a les
meilleurs amis après tout c'est que
l'abstinence avant tout connu avec la
pince ni j'en ai acheté ces points mais
ouais le pinceau ni le personnel venu
natation au début de partie ce ténor fer
de lance
oui et non marion c'est entre 4 nages le
dos vous êtes connu mouillé quand on
était plus souvent mouillé ensemble que
sec
50 50
ouais ouais mais vous continuez à vous
voir mouillé non non je ne vais pas
entrer dans cette couleur ça fait depuis
l'été dernier depuis juin juillet vous
aimez ça être colloque moi j'imagine
qu'à votre art j'aimerais habiter death
of sight bassam en plus on attend notre
salon le salon bureau c'est comme la
place où est-ce qu'on travaille crossley
travail peu après sur comme nos chances
qu'on est un peu dans notre monde
téléphone - c'est le fun michelin salle
oms le redis pêche sont leurs diplômes
on essaye de te passer à se lance pas
autant continue de régner la femme qui
est un brainstorm tant pis on pense au
studio pièces qu'on fait si sûr j'ai
enfin j'aime beaucoup votre univers
wade arrive de la radio yapi tout et tu
vraiment sur le beat matin tout était
prêt mais le matin tour de bonheur j'ai
vraiment pas le choix fait comme avant
ah non pas du tout choix va être de nuit
moi j'aime vraiment vivre le soin puis
même ans quand je me couche bien trop
tendres je me couche vers 10h30 11h
puisque j'ai pas de manquer de l'habitat
peur de manquer de la vie oui je suis
toujours eu chaud oui mais dans showbiz
sur la tête compliqué quand même avoir
la peur de manquer de la ville doit
toujours avoir des soirées ça pour moi
c'est pour la vie le scientifique non
mais j'ai j'ai tout le temps je trouve
que moi c'est ben apportant ma vie que
chaque jour nous ressemble pas la
précédente puis malheureusement j'aime
la radio puis j'aime pyla rajasthan
médiamat tout les jours ouais on aura
mais faut jamais pu toi je viens de
sortie d'un meeting justement je me suis
un monde où les egos et cse jégo c'est
parce que je tout en train de tout
remettre en question
puis de comme d'étranges à quoi s'en
vante pas de cas il faudrait que moi
j'aurais réinventer quelque chose
d'assez ce que la pâte ne pas de
casseurs a changé six fois non plus la
même place puis le segment mais qu'un
footing pour un segment clé pour catch
up
j'avais passé au segment pudding
pourquoi c'est la plus belle texte
pourrait on affirmer mais oui j'ai tout
un besoin que chaque jour naissant pas
la précédente
l'ex pour sa faute au temps de la même
des nouveaux défis you take même stone
wall street
jamais je me couche a même appuyé me
lever de la même façon où je me dis joue
l'attaqué mais bon cela dans le temps de
là de l'autre main comme charles darrow
des oui oui vraiment n'ont jamais
utilisé ce que je me suis blessé l'herne
parce que moi je cours beaucoup plus je
me suis blessé mais j'ai checké un peu
parce que là j'ai une des affaires c'est
qu'ils disent qu'il faut que je change
des souliers de course pour moi je
faisais des cinq lost est effectif car
quand tu fais ce genre de course l'aude
faut compter change à chaque trois mois
oui mais j'ai la même paire de souliers
de nuit je ne sais pas combien de
kilomètres j'ai dû mettre dessus
mais bon j'ai bien vendu ta foi de
plusieurs médecins m'ont dit que quand
tu encourages des gens corrects en
veulent c'est pas bon pour les blessures
des bons sur le court et avec des
mauvaises soulier s'est pas émoussée je
me s'acheter tout s'est tellement gênant
parce que tu ne supportes x essaye à
chaque sport je m'essaye mais quand
votre chercher les vrais bons souliers
de course de fond court et dans le
magazine
non c'est gênant c'est humiliant mais la
nuit mais morts oui c'est vraiment bien
moi j'ai commencé la course me mets en
colère je me suis dit c'est devenu
quelque chose mais j'ai l'impression que
pour toi c'est plus dur contre moi sans
raison moi ça me prend une bonne et
manuscripts une trame sonore parce qu'on
arrive souvent à la même place
quand on court on revient chez nous au
bout du compte vous avez une destination
non puis en même temps j'ai un amour un
aux performances un amour à une à tous
qui comptabilise à blue fait buter tout
ça je déteste c'est quoi ton au pays ses
couteaux et je déteste sauf actuel à
partir amour vient de couacs mais le
sentiment que ça procure de courir
comment sans billet ouais c'était obligé
est en mode performance l'aboutissement
l'importance de bouger quelque chose qui
bouge quelque chose qui devrait pas su
et des cheveux parce que c'est chien
saucisse ou et des chats c'est sûr que
le la course à pied c'est peut-être pas
le truc qui va peut-être pas de faire ce
défi est ce que tu coures lyvan un ton
souliers réguliers ou bien en face aux
blessures
je me suis blessé j'étais massage aller
courir puis la journée où est ce que
j'ai commencé à sentir j'ai tu tombé
dans le fond fait qui en tombant je me
suis relevé dessus historique mais on ne
peut plus tourner encore j'ai commencé à
sentir après ceux survenus chez nous
mais c'est seulement dans mon bureau je
reste le genre immobile mans à peu près
deux heures je travaillais puis à game
et où je n'en avais pas quelque chose et
puis en me levant j'ai failli tomber
j'ai fait deux fautes faire saigner ils
vont suivre
avant je pouvais me dire tu mets ton
quand j'avais
22 23 puis qu'elle choisit la natation
je me blesse c'est que c'est comme ça
dans le bas du dos et ça revenait tout
le temps mais là on quand sa frappe et
l'ange muscles ce genre de blessure là
c'est le verre de blessure qui peut
resté longtemps c'est en prend pas soin
button qui on veut se le dire mais à
force de courir on devient les de la
face trouvé mon lit je trouve qu'on vrai
que la peau du visage d'école avant le
reste que les gens qui courent ont
tendance à main c'est beaucoup trop
face à la personne et on en aura pas de
nom mais c'est encore bien ses quatre co
aurait beaucoup cool parce que
généralement ce que se mata courir y
passer des années de quoi dominique
martini avec dominic arpin lui c'est un
full aux as quoi s'acheter de 40 dans
son coeur ne va que tu viennes devient
dès que tu ne trouves pas bonne ou non
ses joues arrive longtemps après lui non
non mais je sens qu'un excès d'un mois
sa lutte à ce bon enfant qui m'écrit crb
face à l'uruguay oui déjà venu ici
d'ailleurs oui a dit ça brille c'est ce
qu'ils font dans ma carrière son jeu
commence à faire des affaires que ma
fille a déjà fait ça a été longtemps
c'est la mère de cinq enfants de fait le
taf est inverse
c'est un peu partie des médias
traditionnels vers les réseaux sociaux
même si tu es encore des métiers
traditionnels mais tu as quand même mais
c'est pas ça existait comme moi c'est ça
aussi mais je me rappelle de l'animation
de kankan facebook est arrivé puis ma
couenne maîtrise était là dessus troyens
ont tout fait pour montrer des photos
mais oui au traité il faut en tout cas
dans le temps par ta personne ne veut
voir des jo face à ces réseaux sociaux
s'est tous fait tapis ouais mais tout le
monde est ce qu est ce que quelle est la
différence majeure pour toi entre les
deux entre les deux médians climatique
mais médias traditionnels comme la radio
puis les médias sociaux est ce que tu
contrôles vraiment à plat trop minces
qui est ce que tu remarque une tendance
qui te plaît ou déplaît dans les deux
jeunes qui dit oui oui a vraiment les
deux mais g dames zarate qui ont une
évolution où tu contrôles sa plate forme
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'un
t'exposes en toi même sur sa plateforme
tu te c'est comme si tu t'es jamais
autant offerte en même temps de
l'éthique n'importe qui peut récupérer
ton contenu pour en faire une
publication puis maintenant on le voit
beaucoup affecté à 20
pour faire un article dans le séjour où
on te demander d'autorisation faisait
validé theft auto
maintenant tout le monde pique
directement sur notre contexte qui est
public qui gère que des fois tu je pense
pas qu'à 17 ans très exactement qu'est
ce que tu veux faire dans vivendi com
tabler sur une étiquette aussi d'un
enjeu les connus de même à vos resté le
même dans ma tête avec oui un contrôle
de son image mais en même temps je
trouve que le team destructeur je dis
toujours aux avis les réseaux sociaux
avaient existé aussi fort dans le temps
que j'ai commencé ma carrière pro loin
que j'aurais fait 12
parce que rose indien sur un shoot raté
québec reçoit des commentaires des fois
tu veux t'en as far west c'est vraiment
intrusif c'est ya pas de modération
encore sur les plates formes là j'espère
que il va avoir un précédent avec le
code 2d conspirent leur et
constitutionnelles 30 mai à date
n'importe qui peut dire n'importe quoi
mario dumont a justement publié une
photo pour le sport beau de nachos au
fromage mais le fromage ne pas griller
encore ailleurs aller jusqu'à ta femme
c'est une cible très potes l'apport d'un
pouvoir trop appétissant son adjoint
jean le cam iron mines photo portrait
caché dans le mode super bowl ça paraît
que c'est le même jeu conseil des femmes
sert qu'à donner une étiquette je te
pousse un petit peu fou d'attendre
bitchage est resté dans ton salon la
taça tape là tu attends j'ai directement
de l'altantique en vrai c'était plus
compliqué le fallait qui écrit une
lettre non mais c'est ça qui fait que
devaux un être cher oui c'est ça mais un
verre c'est vrai ça reste en service à
l'auditoire ça sera un dépôt à nous mais
il y en avait quand même glas des madame
puis des monsieur oui on les confond le
grand val de travers ou une nouvelle
coupe de cheveux
mais est-ce que tu y mets ton est ce que
le monde
c'est sûr qu'il y avait moins de monde
qui allait parce que c'est sûr que le
monde dit mettons tu regarde une
émission que tu aimes pas c'est même
trop compliqué d'avoir le jeu brenda les
services avant qu'ils allaient viol et
ses lacets comme testons cellular quand
tu vois le truc ça prend une fraction de
seconde je sauve si les gens ça valide
entretuer maintenant moi que j'ai pas
ainsi que peut-être qu'à chanter mal aux
mondiaux deux commentaires qui était
déjà cachant pas le manga rocher dessus
c'est toujours des jeux répondent à ces
questions à ses commentaires sur j'avais
commencé à faire justement parce que
rosa 17e
j'avais commencé à y faire une mosaïque
pour y donner à nos yeux la boucle oui
je crois tout les gens qui l'avaient
détruit pas je voulais montrer que cette
plante un show un soleil un paysage un
but de bd n y avait aucun humain j'ai
arrêté parce j'ai fait loyers ont de
toute façon je lui donne trop
d'attention - c'est aussi la fin d'une
page instagram qui s'appelle tôt québec
sites acquis c'est un un maul c'est
comme on est au québec si métier comme
un peu d'un jargon puis les autres
qu'ils font c'est qu'ils prennent ils
font une publication c'est la photo de
profil de la personne avec un
commentaire c'est toujours trop bon tu
sais je pense que c'était une madame
hier qui coûtait sarr académique des
erreurs et il ya trop d'immigrés
oui mais quoi se montre offensif ont
trop petit oui ce genre et madame le
salaire massandjé pas qu'ils s'apprêtent
à porter qui ont vieilli genre de
personne qui dit qu'en entendant web on
sait jusqu'à au moins il mais il rende
publique la surdité de la chambre
commentant république mais votre photo
de profil aussi votre photo aussi y
mettre les noms et matignon à oui j'ai
tout un pan de souche médias même tard
et c'est ça qui veut t'aider fois il ya
tellement troll maintenant ils veulent
juste l'attention c'est en même temps
c'est un peu de renverser l'intimidation
auxquelles un résultat de l'intimidation
et jamais de rémy des faits que c'est
pas si s'il sait des fois c'est drôle
mais des fois c'est ce jeu c'est pas
toujours la bonne combine que le foot le
foot ça parce que tu sais bien que tu es
fans vont aller de défendre puis ben ali
donne un char de mardi mais facto
mexique et était enfant le tri sont
larges plein pile poil
instagram pts que excuse que tu regarde
s'il ya un danger à ce trimestre ce que
c'est moche et le livre oui oui je l'aï
vu moi je trouve que les filles partie
ferme à mon fils est beaucoup moins
atteints par sow parce que lui y est
plus dans le gaming puis je trouve que
je sais pas pourquoi les lego reste
quand même moins pu même encore joe
peut-être faire un commentaire très
gentil mais même les commentaires
négatifs
le chili s'est souvent défend c'est
souvent des femmes plus vieille aussi
une espèce d'amertume ou je sais pas
quoi où justement le le balcon s'est
transféré mais il est aussi une grande
majorité de femmes qui sont sur les
réseaux sociaux le ver sourigues les
auteurs féminins fait que c'est sûr que
là le pourcentage est plus élevé qu'il
ya beaucoup plus je pense sur facebook
ou si je suppose sans rapport avec l'âge
mais c'est payé pour moi les
commentaires que je lis sur facebook ou
sur instagram
mais les filles je trouve ça ne va pas
ces ions espace manger j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup de difficultés à avoir 8 août
approprient ton image tu as pris ton
corps maillaud les filtres il ya tout ce
à quoi tu ne crois pas tout ce à quoi tu
crois mais que c'est pas la réalité puis
lyon drake
à vingt fallait quand même aller
l'acheter le magazine pour se comparer
et puis voir les ok mais c'est des
mannequins oui mais gagnent leur vie
avec leur carte comprend mais maintenant
c'est tout le monde sait que demain
c'est la pays d'à côté c'est même la
paix avec qui tu vas d'école a réussi à
se faire des photos qui est devenu une
vedette instagram
alors cap a fait plus que toi il ya une
comparaison il ya quelque chose avec le
lay que je trouve très je pense aviez vu
de l'épisode de black mirror justement
où les gens se série sur netflix puis
j'ai tellement rendu ce matin à radio je
parlais justement de un article que
j'avais lu là dessus où tout est du bout
du doigt t tender c'est ok à gauche à
droite
lapointe une vallée dans ma catégorie je
veux aller dans tout ce contrôle par un
doigt mais on s'éloigne de l'humain
comme ça ne se peut pas puis on devient
nous mêmes cette marchandise la de
choisy six mois s'il vous plaît like et
moi dites moi que je ne me balade au mon
dieu j'ai rien publié depuis trois jours
puis avant je me dis ok ben c'est normal
moi je gagne ma vie et des fois avec une
partie de mes revenus maintenant que
bien par instagram anti les réseaux
sociaux so j'avais pas ça à 20 avant
fallait que ça soit ne compagnie
publicité qui m'engagent puis il y avait
une partie sans aller à la personne de
la tâche et 13 pouces mais tabarouette
qu'on est devenu victime de sautes cbi
même moi je me vois bien et je veux que
l'une des plus vieilles dans cette
catégorie là qui quand même un pied des
réseaux sociaux
puis je rencontre des amis comédiens
dans un bouge peu là-dessus h pas la
subida barman qui ont abaissé ce thème
ambitieux dans ces moments là que tu te
rends compte t mettons témoin tome on
friday d'un dans le monde du cinéma et
réalisateur
et puis posera g mes parents quand -1 pt
le fait le plus tu es là tu en fait le
plus ça devient important depuis un an
là dessus plus tu dis plus à manille la
valeur c'est vraiment pour irradier mais
la valeur des gens qu'ils m'en
proportionnelle à son nombre d'abonnés
décolle pas là-dessus tous ceux n'existe
même pas pour ces personnes le psy j'en
sais jamais problème est il tout petit
comme tu dis l'arbaïn
ça existe pas quand mais quand tu donnes
pas l'importance exacte de picasa fait
pas partie ton environnement pitié je
regarde tout le temps je regarde ce
qu'ils ont plein plein plein d'abonnés
puis il ya en assez des pages
publicitaires tout va bien voyons
tweettent a besoin de toutes les
annonces quand on regarde la tv mais tu
vas aller passer la soirée paix toutes
les publicités qui à ce compte là ça me
fascine c'est vraiment on est aux
premiers balbutiements encore je pense
j'espère qu'on va voir un retour en
arrière parce que moi je peux dire de
marotte parce que c'est ma peur de
manquer quelque chose même si tout le
monde arrête pas j'arrêterai pour metz
il est arrêté en arrière tu penses qu'à
man et on va faire ayissi épatant banks
en dessous je sais c'est beau mais avoue
que c'est pas tout petit ce pauvre est
que c'est toutes les influences au musée
les influenceurs qui ont vraiment
contenu pertinent frais non ça il y en a
qui ont des causes y en a qui ont des
missions jeudi s'il faut prêcher pour ma
paroisse mais je sais qu a dit attention
pour apporte des batailles puis tout ça
je me dis ok a peu influencé une partie
d'eux des jeunes qui vont suivre
qu est ce qu a dit jessie fait la même
chose jesse nadeau mais il ya un autre
fait ben voyons donc toi que j'ai
proposé ma photo de chaux pour poser ma
poteau de shopi je rentre là d'un mois
ci dans des valeurs des fois c'est juste
pour garder ta cote puis de savoir que
tu vaux encore sow pour les nuls 17
c'est vraiment c'est compliqué ça parce
que tu es au final je comprends ce que
tu dis de dire moi je veux pas je veux
pas l'arrêter si si tout le monde arrête
pas que ça arrête infondée mais au final
est-il moi je me pose cette question là
activement parce que parce que moitié
garder un ford historic je sais faire
distribuer ce que je veux garder un
engagement élevé pour pouvoir
éventuellement perso collaboration ça
m'intéresse plus du tout je les fait ça
me tente plus ça me rendait pas heureux
ça me rend toujours paru faire ce que
j'ai parlé à d'amour je t'aime quand
régis samson patrick garnier qui passait
en double année parce que moi je les
fais un petit
lui ce qu'il a fait c'est qui a arrêté
de suivre tous non à qui faites la suite
deux personnes qui suit son groupe de
musique dj set son de musique puis caen
qui va sur instagram fait juste posté
puis apprécier plus rien à faire sur un
terrain fait qu'ils ferment sont hong
kong et fait qui interagit peau ils
voient pas ils comparent pas il voit pas
l'ombre de like les autres personnes
font il checke même pas si c'est la jka
lui fait juste possible que ces temps
puis on se parlait l'autre fois au
téléphone par là peu près une heure et
demie puis india quel point ç'a changé
sa vie de faire ce que le maintenant y
ait vraiment mieux qu'ils s'y mettront
les médias sociaux deviennent façon de
promouvoir ses propres trucs team et un
mois avant une plateforme de 115 mille
personnes c'est pratique pour le podcast
audio pour tout les projets que je vais
faire dans l'avenir
mais si ça devient seulement ceux ci se
mettent à vis et c'est négatif mais ça
vient seulement un outil pour promouvoir
c'est correct est fait dans le fond j'en
suis effectivement ça m'amène rien
suivent des gens puis de voir juste
d'aider bob du monde criait après du
monde ce ce cas là c'est la consommation
regardez beaucoup aux jeux parce que
c'est ce parce que tu t'en par poste tu
vois pas quelqu'un d'autre moi médecin
pas mal tous à petit la paix parce que
c'est vrai c'est vraiment rendu comme le
milieu mais le milieu du de la
communauté virtuelle tout sens pas mal
si un aquifère pas de casse toi j'en ai
entendu parler de ces podcasts
ce qui est moins dans le fond en fait le
réfléchissement avoir parce que c'est
une réflexion que je me pose vraiment
ces jours ci en et demain moi mettons le
projet qui me tient le plus à coeur si
ce podcast ci puis le studio s'est faite
là je me dis dans le fond le podcast va
sortir il va exister par lui même puis
bord du monde qui vont l'écouter parce
que du monde qu'il écoute tu as raison
et après ça je m'en fous quelqu'un
d'autre avait fait un autre pas car
enfin si notre podcast on est capable de
d'atteinte des jambes et de continuer à
hydro sourire puis à faire ça mais je me
fous des caisses qui se fait vraiment
fait dans le fond c'est juste ce que toi
tu veux faire que tu met de l'avant puis
avec cette réflexion là on dirait que ce
genre de pression je sais pas ça fait de
chance mais je pense que c'est juste
qu'il garde une relation saine avec 6
extrêmement 17 c puis faudrait être
capable comme comme la simulation de vol
libre est flagrant rapidement le témoin
au moment que tu te sens pub un moment
ça prend trop de place que tu parles
trop donc je te souhaite un rapport de
vous avez passé six heures par jour
c'est rohff non mais ça c'est d'être
capable de le reconnaître rapidement des
métiers de côté ou de se trouver des
trucs justement pour pas tomber dans le
panneau parce qu'ils osent addictif là
dedans
enfin que c'est juste que je parle pas
si mal en soit consommé jusqu'en ça
prend trop de place comme n'importe quoi
n'importe quelle drogue
quand tu te rends compte que tu es plus
déprimés que tu es t elle son téléphone
c'est sûr oui c'est ça moi ses choix je
ressent physiquement que je suis plus
stressé quand je dis oui un thème années
je me suis on était en vacances en
voyage à cuba
marion voyager ensemble aujourd'hui
qu'on l'annonçait le plan c'était genre
est pas mon téléphone qui compta
vacances et puis c'est pour moi voyagé
ces villes où l'éleveur peut y avoir une
valise à faire c'est une école et là
dessus du rien de nouveau que tu voulais
même pas fatigué non c'est clair qu'il
ya juste une soirée qui a été il ya un
paquet ce qui est sorti de retourner là
je pense pas que comme si georges jeu
offert une soirée qui était déposée
histoire et d apathie je peux jobetic
j'ai passé deux ans à faire ce jeu tell
me coucher pileux le je me sentais
stress et si je m'étais pas senti de la
semaine c'est quand même un pied dans la
neige était comme le seul un cadre sur
messi autre côté ça fait tellement du
bien
mais la pire fois c'était à la fois une
fois que je t'ai envoyé avec ma famille
au pérou lé petit c'était un voyage de
deux marches pikes peak pythie je n'aime
pas de résoudre petits hôtels deux
semaines puis tout ajustement la
première semaine je
regardez aucun écran pendant une semaine
c'est non non mais je peux je serai
capable quand même jeu pour la reine de
la publication pis si je fais pas de gpo
fait le post classic de saint valentin
oh mon dieu ça s'émeut nantais pour chat
une faute rythmes jazz au téléphone
après une semaine c'était le mythe ou
gilbert rozon tout est à faire
oui le gel avait même pas entendu par
j'avais un poster ligne en abuser
personnes au pérou il faut qu'elle
pourrait cesser comme une autre planète
quand même à déconnecter mais genre
ouais je faisais des erreurs dans cette
semaine le que j'avais et sous-bois
tiges dit andré que georges de connecter
le risque d'un chien courant à bréville
c'est seul que ça a quelque chose sur
notre cerveau que vous avez vu elon musk
le maudit foule qui est en train
d'inventer la cuisse et des années avant
la fin 2021
on va pouvoir tester sur un humain une
puce qui va se contrôler que va
contrôler des appareils électroniques
avec des ondes cervicales terrain
tabarouette ça c'est ça s'approche
tranquillement win a mis dans trois
caches en podcast maintenant mais tesla
pour les cochons qui ont des orgasmes
pendant 30 minutes
oui un cochon une tortue ok tu penses la
national geographic ont complètement la
porte oui oui moi aussi je pense qu'à
des cochons ils font selon ta part ça a
été
mon chemin mentale bon me rends demain
j'y invite aussi le lancement de trois
cochons qui parle de colis cochon
prépare laissé coi mettant une
conversation plus intéressante que chez
des cochons pc parlement sinon ils font
aussi à une autre expérience qui font
sont capables de même plus aux jeux
vidéo ou si les cochons ça la puce del
bosque lui ont découvert swank le
joystick avec os avec une friandise
ouais c'est fou ce toit ces pictogrammes
et l'us trets devenir mais non non on
parle et on est parti dans son chemin
cervicales pc le conservant sa joue un
rôle dans ton cerveau sawiris et ont pu
depuis ce sacre est quelque chose y
avait des études qui disait qu'il aimait
tant qu'indien like rentrer sa série de
quatre concerts bref qui devient
addictif tout ça c'est problématique
non mais tu es je disais l'autre jour je
sais pas ce qu'elle plate forme je pense
que facebook instagram qui pensaient
enlever la fonctionnalité live existants
us en pis je sais pas je sais pas si
mettons dans 20 ans on va zeyd de 2015 à
quelle époque et like ceux qui savent à
son ancien nous savons être pire le tipi
west ham à voir décote sur cinq étoiles
à la blague pour coter directement ses
sauts sont la fois plus qu'on peut plus
touchés on pourra plus touchés notamment
l'accession il va falloir qu'ils veulent
maintenant on a vite su à chris noth pas
de gaspiller donner un meeting de 2 sur
ce que tu sais quand on entre dans ton
parcours des médias pour retirer ce qui
te sens une jarre de d'attitude au thème
par rapport au fait que tu utilise les
réseaux sociaux est ce qu'est cette
espèce de dynamique l'eau non mais
peut-être peut-être un petit goût même
titre qu'il y avait une espèce de
dynamique me cache sortie l'école de
théâtre de aoued fait partie des atouts
batelli et qui avait comme une espèce de
snobisme aussi mais que peut-être que yo
mais en même temps c'est tellement
depuis moi je pense qu'on est vraiment
entré on est dans le bec verseur c'est
les stars du web commence à faire de la
télé de plus en plus on va chercher
justement puis même quand tu fais de la
télé ou la radio on regarde combien taux
d'abonnés soit parce que c'est la plate
forme de conte cité la plus facile
est ce que tu penses que toi 7,7
that a ouvert des portes je suppose je
suis moi je suis rendu à un stade où tu
sais j'ai quoi loger en 2050 dont deux
médecins
puis j'ai tellement choisi de cacher
cette année de cette porte selon moi je
te porte va faire d'autres choses je
sais pas qu'est-ce qui moquaient ce qui
m'a aidé qu'est ce qui m'ennuie ça
m'ennuie probablement de penser plus ma
personnalité qui m'ennuie que le que ça
m'a aidé oui à chaque année à peu près
ce qu'il appelle c'est que c'est même
pas des projets concernant qui marchent
pas c'est des projets que je m'attende
moi j'ai vraiment le jeu vraiment
connecté sur ma flandre ah non je sens
plus fait que je serai plus divertissant
je serai plus intéressé je suis vraiment
une butineuse de mais ce que j'aime des
projets n'en font-ils branson s'est
trouvé l'idée une fois qu'on a trouvé
l'idée
ok on va faire le trou au foie parfois
on fait le tour de tout ce qui est ce
que dans ce parcours le te sauter mais
ton de ce film c'est un projet parce
qu'il t'a menaient plus que de chercher
sans avoir le prochain projet de prêt
non with - fait que tu te lances et le
tu partais mettons d'une de dengue et
d'animation qui réclament un bon salaire
qui permettait d'être stable tu te
faisais ça me tente plus oui le met en
danger financièrement ou en danger de de
carrière ou à meilhan aucune des 2 6 ans
j'étais chanceuse j'ai jamais eue
l'aspect financier jamais fait partie de
mes décisions qui tu vois métaux comme
quand j'ai quitté et 2 filles le matin
keita quand même quotidienne à la télé
que je faisais depuis cinq ans ça a été
le décès de mon père qui a peut-être
comme un jouet coop couch très très à
l'affût aussi de des signes la vie du
jeune et d'accompagnement pas pendant
trou au mois pour la compagnie va la
mort plus tard prévoyons donc ça fait
quatre fois que j'interviewe michel
ribes cherche emprunt je sais plus quoi
il était accusé pas intéressant non non
non je porte quel point intéressant mais
j'avais de la misère à boire puis j'ai
besoin d'être nourris ou si j'ai besoin
de sentir coquet appartement quelque
chose de nouveau
explique moi quelque chose que je
prenais pas dis moi que tu apprends moi
n'est que quand j'avais l'impression
d'être dans un
une guégot j'apprenais plus rien où
j'avais l'impression justement de
devenir un peu seul qui en sait
peut-être plus que l'autre sur soi parce
que je l'expérimenté je partais mais
c'est dommage car j'aurais pu finir par
devenir excellent dans quelque chose je
suis toujours tu es toujours le rocher à
faire avant de devenir vraiment très
bonne ou spécialistes dans quelque chose
mais on dirait que je peux pas
m'empêcher de trouver un peu ce triste
mois ceux qui sont restés dans la même
affaire
ses pieds en même temps je trouve ça
beau lot et il ya des gens qui accumule
les trophées parce que ses succès à long
terme que tu finis par à boiter
reconnaissance parce que tu es tellement
longtemps mais je salut bonjour
mais non mais c'est bon écoute avec star
louis a eu du bon pour lancer météo il
est bon pour non je pense pas je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui sont faits pour
quelque chose de plus routinier patins
et puis moi j'ai encore la perspective
d'un monde famille vienne madrid puis je
me dis peut-être qu'un jour on va les
vivent en espagne je toujours rage
toujours à l'attendre d'une prochaine
vie on dirait comme si c'était pas assez
peu suffisante et celle-là ya dessus un
projet est un projet de carrière quelque
chose que tu as pas fait que toute
réforme attend mais sûrement tu sais je
veux écrire un livre ça je me dis un
jour faut vraiment j'écrive un livre
mais on dirait que ça me prend
l'histoire qui vont homme que je vous
dis ok ça ça me tente et je me fais
offrir tout le temps comme la mode les
yeux plus de livres que de lecteurs puis
je me ferais ont été pensés de visiter
par côté mais non j'étais je l'achèterai
peau avec un roman je sais pas mais j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup d'imagination je le
sais j'ai beaucoup de tir juste mon jeu
c'est que j'ai quelque chose à faire
avec son soutien journal intime depuis
l'âge de 13 ans je n'ai jamais arrêté
puis a vraiment tout dépende viger des
cayes étudiants qui soit c'est le
divorce ça c'est bon j'ai quelques
cahiers le divorce il ya vraiment
quelque chose de l'fun mais quand je
relis je me dis la petite fille de 13
ans à qui est devenu cette femme-là de
49 ans s'est on a tous le même parcours
pompage
il ya vraiment des fils conducteurs
étonnant dans les choses que j'écrivais
à 80 ans que je peux avoir écrit à 30
sur libre du fait qu'un
oui sous va lire mathon cette équipe
faisait je le faisais beaucoup avec ma
fille parce que j'avais c'était comme ma
façon passer sa crise d'adolescence
rosalp immense apport c'est beaucoup par
les mots parce qu'on aime beaucoup les
mots de l'un d'eux puis quand elle avait
15 âge lisez mon journal intime avec
elle quand j'avais 15 ans fait qu'on
confrontée la mélanine 15 1 avec sa
rosalie 15 souvent de trouver proche la
ducati fait jamais tenus tenaient encore
chat ou non d'entrer l'ipd draconis en
même temps oui mais moi je trouve que en
vieille saint plus je vieillis plus je
ressens mal à mélanie ados ah ouais moi
je sais vraiment j'ai hâte que quelqu'un
fasse une thèse un peu plus exhaustive
de ma propre expérience personnelle j'ai
vraiment l'impression que plus on
vieillit plus on redevient on ressemble
à la base ce qu'on était l'espèce de mt
400 adolescents loeb 5e tout tout
bouillant d'inquiétantes a des envies
des fois on aperçoit de la recherche
mais des fois c'est juste la vraie
personnalité qui s est senti malgré tout
et malgré les influences je vais avance
une théorie parce que j'ai pas ce que
j'ai déjà réfléchi puis l'idée est que
quand t'es jeune t'es tu pose pas la
question de savoir qui tu étais juste
huer existe exacte et après ça tu prends
le temps gens qui qu'est ce que les gens
ont envie c'est quoi l'image que tu vois
que les gens ont de toi tu dirige
tranquillement vers cette image là
jusqu'à dakar en et se redresse la
direction quand tu connais plus en
vieille simple tu réalises kellock et je
partis du cij rendu là mais ça c'est
plus que j'étais effectué redresse vers
kit était simplement j'adore ta théorie
oui puis en plus tu tally aussi tout
connaît pas l'hôte recherche tout allié
avec des personnes que tu crois qu'ils
te ressemble qui renvoie une image de
toi que tu penses qu'il à bonn puis un
moment donné ça peut pas le quelqu'un de
rock et non t'as pas ça non plus mais
oui moi j'aime beaucoup ça j'aime
beaucoup d'heures on ce modèle aussi au
regard des autres puis pas je sens
conforme à ce que la société au lieu de
vouloir avec moi j'ai l'impression
villesange devient de plus en plus
robert que je l'assumé
c'est vrai qu'on va manger chez
directeur laurent duporge que j'ai mais
j'ai passé mon adolescence l'eau mais
c'était non non je
j'aime ça j'aime savoir seulement m ont
duré de retrouver la personne au centre
c'est peut-être pas évolué peut pas
appeler les choses non mais c'est quand
même triste parce que ça veut dire qu'on
perd un foutu temps à essayer de se
conformer à ce que les autres ont
l'impression qu'on aime ou qu'on devrait
mais est ce qu'on perd un teint ou
est-ce que c'est essentiel de farce pour
être capable de se recentrer sur la
question il se fait ça là c'est la
question que les avk que s'est posée
justement dimanche soir chez moi une
question qu'on a parlé avec mon fils
parce que moi j'ai toujours au par un
grand emprunt
ma grande crainte dans la ville toujours
que la vie c't'une ging puis on sait
tous qu'on veut finir en bout de la
table même virginie fortin des actions
plus riche qu'un exploit je le dis à ce
poste là je viens d'avoir déjà vu je
suis vraiment dit à 7,3 dans le podcast
de legault qui dans des chalets c'est
pas un manque de respect mais tout ça
pour dire que oui je pense que c'est une
gang qui sait ce que je disais à mon
fils parce que mon fils lui team est on
là il veut faire du rap là il veut être
à los angeles il veut réussir il veut il
se voit tout de suite alors que moi je
trouve que dans vivo par son hôte et de
calme je pense qu'on perd son sorte
d'école ce que met 8 qui dit puisse
ouvrir ma fille c'est à dire ça si on la
vie nous amène à d'autres quand ça veut
pas dire que tu me manques et décale ça
veut dire que tu dois apprendre
autrement mais moi j'ai l'impression
juste un peu juste un peu j'ai
l'impression que chaque étape de la vie
apporte c'est à pâtisser comme des
enfants vedettes des fois les enfants
vedettes qui ont commencé à travailler
trop tôt ils deviennent très vite blasé
sur des plats doute des plateaux de
tournage puis je pense qu'ils ont manqué
un espèce de ou est-ce que la
personnalité se forment l'allemand
normalement au contact de thé pas un pli
du coude en faveur des demandes que
savait pas non parce que c'est quand tu
vis pas quelques pavés cette période le
ton enfance tous ces mets ton justement
des idées ou des buts nice pèserait
saura des adultes mais sont encore des
enfants parce qu'ils n'ont jamais
vraiment véhicules ont les otsi rétro on
a trop tiré sa tige doit être votre sur
toutes les cases le ph
dernièrement
dernièrement je me suis j'ai je tombe
sur une une pensée qui tirait du
bouddhisme qui dit qu' il ya aucune
chose que tu aurais pu faire qui
auraient pu être différentes puis aucun
endroit où est ce que devrait plus être
qui aurait pu être différent puis une
fois tu dises us il ya quand même on
dirait que comme une acceptation du
chemin que tu parcours
maintenant qu'elle est rendue pis je
sais que ça fait quand même et au tehrik
de dire ça pique un peu là c'est quand
même un peu le destin
ben c'est un peu la pensée fataliste de
dire on est tous tirs c'est le destin
qui nous mais rien n'arrive pour rien
pigé haïtien peut dire ça sauf que
l'idée de dire maintenant il je pourrais
nulle part ailleurs qu'ici en même temps
en ce moment je trouve ça amène un
certain réconfort piger ainsi penser
comme ça parce que sinon on dirait que
ça devient un petit peu étourdissant de
remettre en question les choix est fait
tout le temps c'est un peu ma pensée
actuellement puisque pour répondre à la
question est ce que tu sautes décale
j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque jour là la
journée et comme celle là c'est la seule
journée j'aurais pu vivre et y fait que
chaque chaque année mais ça vaut dans
moi je pense que cette théorie doivent
être la même dans mon discours de mr
aussi de je veux pas que l'anc l'école
quoi je pense cure dents ça parce que je
trouve justement à cause des réseaux
sociaux à cause de cette espèce de
phénomènes de vedettes instantanées
tabarouette on dirait que la formation
est en train de prendre le banc il ya
plein de jeunes artistes qui réussissent
sans avoir continué l'école qui laisse
quand même prouvé dans toutes les études
sur le bonheur que les gens qui ont une
formation universitaire sont
généralement plus heureux parce que gary
plus achevée sur le marché du travail
je pense que c'est mes passions le sport
qu'on avec mon fils je comprends mais en
même temps nous on savait arrêté qu'un
bon boulot j'ai fait un bac le j'ai
commencé une maîtrise j'ai abandonné ma
maîtrise notre époque
je mettrai en quoi amuser
vraiment moi il manque un stage pour mon
bac et imaginative mais mettons moi
j'étais j'ai fait tu mon cégep à musique
universal music à québec puis j'ai un
cousin qui dix ans plus jeune que moi
qui qui qui adoucit mieux jouer de la
musique ou seppi lui voulait faire ils
voulaient face au sipi lui italie jeudi
en californie et il me dit moi je vous
êtes inquiet je trouve ça vous êtes le
goty de dire je fais un gros mouvement
si je trouve qu'il est remonté comme moi
étaient sur petite fille et mon oncle et
ma tante est comme un fils françois et
inti les états unis toutes mes crimes il
le fait plus flamand que faisait tomber
fait que c'est un peu limité plein les
chaussettes ifec la question si c'est
quoi le pire que prévu c'est quoi le
pire qui va être aimé ton tu décides de
dire ok moi le jeu prend les économies
je m'envoie en californie puis je la
saint yves est situé loin le pire qui va
arriver c'est que ça marchera pas ce
sera peut-être trois peut-être tête
j'aurais avoir de la misère à m arriver
pendant une couple de mois tu vas être
obligé d'être de faire la plonge dans un
resto pour les fins de mois tu vas
revenir plus tu vas faire bon mais cette
expérience là et dans mon sac à dos
d'expérience avant d'avoir servi à ça va
pas marcher comme j'aurais windham hon
dans mon rêve serait pas marcher comme
ça mais au final ça aurait été une
expérience que j'aurai vécu
non non je suis ambitieux aussi le puits
4 sur met en perspective l'on tombe
encore j'ai d'être le chemin
traditionnel jeu d'accord mais faut
qu'ils aient un chemin il faut qu'il
faut que je pense que l'objectif c'est
d'avoir c'est que chaque jour tu
deviennes mieux une meilleure personne
foxit à chaque matin dans ce dakar
coincé sur serre chaque matin je
poursuis ta quête d un objectif à chaque
tipi justement pitt ont fait ce qu'il
veut je commencerai pas dire que mal de
temps
mais son objectif est clair la disquette
si j'aime bien mieux ce que quelqu'un de
25 ans qui chez ses parents qui gagne
toute la journée travaille pas son
objectif mais je n'ai pas qu'ils soient
déçus ça fait ça au cinéma quand j avais
du chemin derrière tu as fait trop mon
dieu s'il est sympa il va être des
soucis c'est derek lee sas pour un sou
et déçu plus tard dans sa vie plus
longtemps pas mal de jeunes qu'eux mais
en même temps leurs noms mais je
l'essayé puis finalement j'ai pris mes
sauts ou totalement sa posture peut-être
qui lui vaut avant tout peut-être qui a
marché parce que les moutons mer le
trouvez-vous que les maires sont pas
bonnes avec les fils moi en tout cas en
tant que maire le ch vraiment moins bon
avec mon fils qu'avec ma fille j'ai
l'impression que vous n'avez pas des
mères qui n'ont su retrouver autour du
pot car la seule poubelle mais on dirait
qu'on voit le pays retrouve tandis que
ce soit au club ça serait quoi le pire
pour arriver à moi dans ma tête j'avais
mes trafic d'organes qui ne met médecin
puis dans le fond je réalise maintenant
l'échec le ce serait quoi allécher
au final c'est juste moi mais ça c'est
les mots de parents qu'on n'a pas de tir
n'a pas qu'ils soient isolés dans cour
d'école on a peur qu'ils soient cédés
par un cocktail accompagneront veut pas
que nos enfants souffrent puis qu'on
veut lui épargner de tous ces séances
c'est lorsque tu as dit énorme rêve le
petit parc était paré antique que la vie
est juste des possibles t je sais
comment ce beau petit répit le mettons
une maudite y mettons déjà 30 harmonie
qui t'arrive tu dis bah qui ma vie ça ça
risque de ressembler à ses pieds à date
c'est des hopis pense pas qu'il va
arriver là grosse affaire tient même est
en moi le rêve de ton fils à 16 ans je
l'avais aussi mais si je voulais faire
la musique puis je voulais qu'ils aient
ça marche puis je voulais que ce sera la
grosse frappe je me voyais un pic tu
fais pied au fur et à mesure que tu le
fais tu te rends compte que finalement
le dit c'est un fait ça sera peut-être
pas exactement ce petit rêve se
transforme terrain de vienne
d'autres affaires étaient heureux quand
même dans ce processus lui et puis tout
se chargent pile est aujourd'hui tard
vers une place que j'aurais pas
nécessairement penser que jamais pensé
en plus fort des podcasts ce ne sera pas
pour tout mais je n'aurais pas pensé
être exactement losc parce que
j'imaginais mais j'suis batterie pis
mais je suis aussi rendu là parce que
j'ai rêvé quand j'avais 16 ans
dominique trétout pied c'est bon ca
nantes avait raison que tu as raison
parce que c'est mon propre père qui
parle pour les autres tout bas c'est sa
vie c'est l'euro qui est passé par lyon
basket et était la première de ce que tu
dis depuis tantôt de temps à arrêter
quelque chose quelque chose d'autre tout
le monde sait ce qu'on voulait manger
vite et si c'était ça le message qu'on
voulait pas payer maintenant tu as
raison mais en même temps c'est
tellement on est toujours rendu avec le
brave tchê cosco l'impression tout le
monde la dgre un grand rêve andric a
plus personne qui on dirait qu'on est en
train d'enlever les lettres de noblesse
à la belle petite vie ont un peu plus
simple un peu moins pourquoi faut
toujours et dans des jeux pense qu'il
faut sur le cloud avec ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure par rapport aux réseaux
sociaux les os que le rêve a été
formateur en tête comme étant une
certaine idée tiqui la réalité c'est que
ceux qui la plupart des gens qui vivent
une vie heureuse
rappelons la puissance est maintenant le
symbole le meilleur terme parce que le
temps des choses les plus importantes
pour toi ta famille et tes amis tu étais
bien les sept
c'est pas ce monde là qui font qu'ils
sont au mexique avec surya
mais c'est important démontrer cela
aussi pour que les gens puissent voir
justement ceux qui consomment les
réseaux sociaux je vois que ça se peut
comme moi j'ai commencé à faire à
montrer ma mère d'un réseau sociaux
parce que ya pas de personnes âgées des
réseaux sociaux tout le monde et laisse
tout le monde et offre un peu la même
affaire puis je suis triste en même
temps je vois ma propre disparition des
gens la voient à la télé on sait que des
compagnes les vues et 40 à 45 4 commence
à sentir que tout fait aussi avec
remédier en plus les réseaux sociaux
doit être aussi laissé une forme c'est
toi quand tu es jeune tu veux rêver
aussi
ce départ avait de la petite vie moi je
les simples et non routinière je voulais
sortir avec viola pas je te montrerai de
girolata mais deux noms mais oui c'est
bizarre mais c'est parce que j'ai très
drôle je trouve elle aussi comme le
premier gré drôle que j'ai vu en plus il
y avait tout un manteau moi j'ai pas de
menton ja c'est vrai que bon ben on
entend par exemple
mais comment tu fais médecin de bambi
justement tombe c'est comme sur menthon
centre de saab a rapporté alors oui oui
en plus aux autres ils faisaient de lui
maupied coûte moi j'ai mis les pros les
pianos rien la première fois de certains
la maman me dis que ça existait pas au
moral
nous garde décor région que c'était
comme c'est ce qu'on mettait le piano
rien on se faisait violer et on se
faisait il nous arrivait tout mais
d'études su tchami avec guy aujourd'hui
oui c'est drôle ça va ça fait partie des
personnes politiques m'impressionne
encore parce que je suis resté comme une
petite fille c'est seulement mon
adolescence être très présent que quand
ils m'ont sorti coréen en russie sur le
plateau shirt devenu comme une épaisse
mais guillot ça mais ma famille mais il
est obligé de me dire à 20 mélanie
depuis 15 ans
en diesel mais en même temps c'est pas
mal pas mal beau rôle du corps d'amy au
calcul pas comme se mêlant peep-toe
woippy guillas a pas partie des gens que
parce que je le trouve brillant comme
que j'ai jamais arrêté de le trouver
brienne gens contre mon scrapbook de guy
a lepage et dans toutes mes photos que
j'ai pris avec comme cité par pti mais
non il reste quelques uns qui
m'impressionne c'est un des personnes
tech j'avais demandé aux lions gate et
portant des portraits tout le monde
entende pour moins d'appels longtemps
que ça existe qu'ils reposent les mêmes
questions écrit ces mêmes cartes en main
capote et puis non tu vois ça fait
partie des les gens qui sont capables de
garder un job qui continue à se
réinventer
mais tu vois ce genre de job dit un peu
comme le podcast je comprends pas les
deux métiers de 70 du nouveau monde
oui oui à chaque semaine on apprend où
je n'ai appris sur toi cette semaine en
tout cas faisant mes recherches mais
nécessaire aux ex tout le temps nouveau
bilan j'avais michèle richard toutes les
semaines des attaques à manille comme tu
dis oui j'aurais pu commander mais là
j'en aurai plein de questions mais
cherchant le toit j'aimerais savoir mais
je pense que l'autre affaire aussi c'est
que amender la télé je trouve ça lourd
parce que quelqu'un rapide quelqu'un qui
aime que ça évite ne remet pas la
préparation de l'atelier jamais pas
l'encadrement de nos sorties du pot ce
qu'on nous fournisse des questions
j'aime la liberté de la radio la liberté
des podcasts mais pas sans traiter
quelqu'un j'aimerais qu'il était
quelqu'un de très v tant que ces pauvres
et non non non non non puis comme tu me
disent quelque chose à ma pause puisque
ça en bloc sa première fois je me dis
rien c'est ça fait que toi peut-être
arrêter ben may dans des shows de télé
réalité ou des choses comme ça où c'est
vraiment on remet ans mais de plus en
plus le focus sur le fait mais j'ai
pensé pour moi je les coupe je me tire
est capable d'être à bec blanc j'ai été
contacté ou non non non les pas du tout
non parce que je pense qu'il contactait
personnes qui ont un job à temps plein
en question disponibilité mais je sais
pas qu'est-ce qui se passerait à big
browser
non est-ce que vous l'écoutez dommages à
l'écouté mais moi je l'écouté je trouve
ou plutôt je devais 4.5 sur park assist
est pas un pandémie on l'écouterait mais
pas mais on dirait que le mille pieds à
l'engrenage farandou
c'est comme chaque saison d'occupation
double à chaque début de saison modèles
embarquent pour la marque paul à la
dernière loge pas mentionné la création
du monde ou est ce qu'on voudrait c'est
quand même beaucoup mieux
oui oui c'est miss et damien faible
calibre et pulsé comme instruction de il
se passe d'affaires comprend pas trop
mais je fais mon jeu mon cher lors de
mon char lui de salon gérants d'estrade
en gérant d'estrade fera pas fait sa
demande piétons non lui-même à toi tu
écoutais pierre non moi je pense monter
mon temps libre à gay mais pas mal
ok toujours un coin mais voyons mais
semble qu'on jouait à ce qu'un conte à
12 mais ça manque à ce qu'annonce
vieillit avec moi ce soir
depuis ce que j'écoutais au dès cette
année mais c'est parce que la belgique
c'est la première épisode puis j'ai vu
ça j'ai fait non non non non non c'est
pas vraiment à va être mieux est aussi
con ça puisse paraître est mieux investi
un gamer et sa retraite sportive à la
drf à rodez n'ont pas toutes les balles
non non mais tu serais tu encore un
kevin qui reviendrait donc puis moi
mettons pour aller un peu plus libre
dans ma perception d'occupation double
puis des téléréalités maintenant j'ai un
problème éthique avec avec faire de
l'argent sur le dos de troubles mentaux
j'ai de la difficulté avec ce témoin je
les vues de première main des moments de
mon année tiao des même si tu penses que
tu est stable tu vas être poussé à
l'extrême c'est moi moi je suis un geek
dans ma vie tous les jours je suis le
treut stable si j'ai pas de sots du
monde depuis mai maraudage été poussé à
bout de ces deux craqué j'ai craqué ou
s'il en est qui apporte joie ni moins
je dis non non mais je les ai vus parce
que en rentrant à rodez est en processus
de de thérapie très clairement un
thérapie oui pendant au des fois ils
l'ont sorti des maisons pour la faire
communiquer avec avec ses proches parce
qu'ils étaient sur le bord de craquer
puis il a ramené la maison il ya sauvé
puis il faisait de l'argent sur le fait
qu'à qui était instable émotionnellement
puis que depuis qu'il est petit et la
preuve c'est quand il sortit alors
refait des thérapies pour se remettre du
jeudi puis le dit je veux plus rien
savoir à quel point est-ce que tu
concrétise monétairement sur des gens
qui ont des troubles mentaux puis en
faisant le casting oui on signe tous le
papier on est d'accord avec toi sauf que
à quel point tu est en position pour
accepter qui tu lis ton image que me
veulent puisqu'ils gardent dans
l'aventuré de francs même si dit oui je
vais rester je restais amené faut que
quelqu'un prenne la décision de faire
non c'est pas bon pour personne en ce
moment si tu sais pas qu'est ce que ça
va fabian plus il ya comme un
pourcentage qui leur est remis à tête et
oblige étrange après s'être année y
avait pas ceux à qui on signe un contrat
qui ont vu que ça donne et que nous on
est sorti on avait 150 et sur instagram
avez donné votre vie moi c'est ça qui me
fait capoter en même temps l'émission a
boosté affectés sur une autre question
mais mais le point que je veux dire
c'est que non je le ferai pas parce que
je trouve que je trouve que dans le
casting choisir des gens qui sont qui
sont instables qui sont eux qui disent
qu'ils veulent le faire mais de les
garder l'ofppt et de continuer à
alimenter sa part de leurs doléances et
offrent quand l'amant pour cette
personne ne sait pas bon pour elle c'est
une image pas bon pour sa santé mentale
qui est vraiment bon pour la production
par qui le demande parce que là ils
l'ont joué là continuent à piller tuer
fake fait que la réponse est non c'est
un problème éthique mon avis puis rama
yade et a pas envie qu'on ferait juste
une fois puis qu'on ferait jamais ça il
ya plein de rôles que je referai pas où
il ya plein de choses qu'on fait des
entrevues qu'il prend une photo fera pas
sans un sou leurs frais par exemple si
louis puis même s'il regrette un petit
peu de maîtrise et encore c'est une
question éthique mots c'est pourquoi
j'ai arrêté parce que
il voulait juste montrer le côté le côté
candyland de sortie iron man star on
voit très bien que tu un jouet brisé à
bientôt raccompagne raconté son enfance
par sa main puis on a eu des scènes
extraordinaires assisté à des choses
humainement que tu dis oh my god faut
que ça soit vu par tout puisque pau mais
non parce que l'industrie en même temps
avaient accepté qu'on ait accès aux
coulisses du 3 x mais en ne montrant que
le bon tu es en montrant tout en
apportant pas un jugement fait que moi
ça m'intéressait plus dans ce pauvre et
je vois les mousses et cette industrie
doit de faire où j'ai toujours été d'un
format non moi je suis tombé dedans
quand j'étais jeune puis aussitôt que je
vois un gars tu ne peux pas m'empêcher
les côtes j'ai vu des scènes d'une
tristesse épouvantable d'hugo qui est
pas capable de qui est pas capable de
faire ce pour quoi ils étaient engagés
qui est objet de recouvrer son c'est de
la pure garder de la pointe tellement
l'a fait à côté rien [ __ ] une goutte
d'eau mais parce que la file à l'umpp
aux genevois la fesci à la table tout le
plateau atteint pendant que lui se
recréer annoncé christophe rey mais
j'imagine que de le faire selon tes de
le faire avec moi qu'il produit
j'aimerais j'aimerais ça parce que trois
mois je pus capable de regarder de la
pointe depuis que j'ai faite de cette
émission le fait que je me dis
probablement que ça fera un beau tir il
ya eu beaucoup de problèmes avec
l'industrie de la pointe de il ya eu des
dénonciations il aurait dû la vengeance
par vidéo sexuelle aussi d'aider jeune
fille avait été abusée qui sont rendus
compte que leur leur vidéo se retrouver
lors parce que peu de contrôle s'est il
y aurait probablement moi ça ferait
partie d'une de mes missions de messages
de fer tabarouette regardez qu'est ce
que vous consommez c'est c'est moi je
trouve que le troupeau c'est un peu
comme comme du mcdo magnifique sud aride
les personnes qui cavalent d'avoir
d'imagination pour nous de le faire
autrement il ya de moins en moins de
relations de couple aussi que je lisais
de relation sexuelle à deux partenaires
de plus en plus l'image de la
masturbation est en hausse mais les
relations de couple son temps en chute
libre
il ya trop de casse pipe de trop pour
annoncer mon départ en tournée
désert mais effectivement un bon point
c'est pete et surtout sur les sites les
plus pauvres à qui pointent comme tant
d'autres de fourre-tout de soda et puis
tous les enfants qui sont pros le mans
fait de manière éthique mais d'autres
vraiment un peuple ils disent qu'ils ont
fait un ménage récemment qu'ils ont
enlevés oui ce qu'ils étaient kimo
louche le ca me fait 4 matic emmène la
catégorie tine la voir
oui oui c'est vrai qu'à look beaumes
elliott suis vraiment beaucoup moins
dense que j'assiste et j'ai pas vu grand
personnes sorties le carte d'identité
puis c est ce que ping
pour moi ça reste l'espèce de davantage
de collège que j'ai jamais compris le
depuis que je suis jeune je ne comprends
pas quand le fait qu' il ya des gars qui
vont aller trippé sur le look d'une
écolière prix plus bas un écolier oui ça
c'est ça exactement
non mais effectivement qu'il y aurait
six jeunes garçons puis à 26 ans un
autre affaire qui m'angoisse ado dit tu
vas tu vraiment apprendre la section 10
jeunes à toutes les filles que je
demandais ce que vous avez joué pour
vrai est ce que combien de fois vous
avez atteint le regard pour red et quand
j'ai pas eu une réponse positive sans
travail il travaille c'est déjà un prix
exact fait que je me dis tu peux pas tu
peux pas monter quand même en train de
ta brevets d'image de fait qui ont l'air
d'être tripes et de n'avoir trop sur eux
autant même tant pis il fonde en face
puis on est donc ça le chauve précieux
moyen d'amasser c'est vraiment mon
raisonnement par rapport à ça c'est que
ces deux choses complètement différentes
la sexualité ma section la pomme
ces deux choses c'est cette fonction
c'est ça mais parce que pim et j'ai
l'impression que si c'est si on avait
accès à pollock
comme on n'a que ça pourra maintenant
quand qu'on découvrait la sexualité le
ma perception serait vraiment différente
parce que parce que j'aurai grand dixon
si oui alors que là mes premières
expériences et qu'un mec avec ma
il y avait de la poigne qui existaient
mais n'en a plus complexes leurs débuts
les mauges monsieur à télécharger est l
ouvrage na waie une image plus à faut
toutefois à l'autre l'ama les terrains
le voile est simple oui oui c'est juste
une fille qui n'a même plus de coprah
faut jouer une fille qui n'était ce pas
que ça soit fini lors des 21 décembre si
c'est parce que tu prends la connexion
internet
c'est compliqué c'est vraiment un
conflit non mais c'est quand même fou
l'accessibilité pareil pour toutes mais
sa tentative était capable - ya quelque
chose d'un petit peu même si mais même
si on se rappelle arcades à ce titre ce
n'est pas la réalité parce que c'était
regarde beaucoup à man et c'est sur ça
s'imprime à quelque part magnifique ça
joue dans la partie surtout des jeunes
cerveaux et ponts mon dieu comment tu
prêt ils vont thuram en fait la vraie
expérience à ce qu'ils ont dit oui on a
de la poigne éthique maintenant de plus
en plus de la pointe féministe mais est
ce qu'ils vont vraiment aller regarder
ça de s'abonner à un site de points de
féminisation du cnit à côté je pense que
je pense que plus les filles qui vont
aller consommer s'appelait govou
continue consommer l'imam puisse écrire
encore l'espèce de différence et
protable entre la sexualité des
chipmunks cclat surtout à un âge
moschetti je sentais vraiment jari matti
j'ai l'impression que attention ce que
tu dis toi que l'aviation
oui vous savez des plaintes heures de
mix
non mes tickets 1 go j'ai nommé les alès
arkel les adolescents oui tu es c'est
vraiment comme oumou sy je me ramène au
quand j'étais adolescent fin secondaire
j'ai pas l'impression que les petites
filles de ma classe qu'on était égal
c'est la faillite vieilli puis la manne
et le on se rattrape ses pieds mais un
stage le pack leur fille si en plus tu
étais la perception ta conception des
sexualités ses soucis il ya un décalage
immense les carences et les premières
clôtures encore mettons ces deux
personnes là qui ont des perceptions
vraiment différente
puis dépit des des raisonnements
vraiment différent par rapport à ceux
qui au niveau une relation sexuelle
ensemble la première alors qu'amiens sa
perception ses skis tchèque
les jours de l'autre la perception c'est
ce qu'elles l'imaginent
mais j'espère que dionne s'est quand
même il ya beaucoup plus d'éducation je
trouve qu'il fait sur la sensibilité de
l'homme tout ça même outil d'un série
notre flix comme sex education ou un
normand pipo et ont des coachs
d'intimité maintenant une feuille qui
est engagée expressément pour aller
placer les scènes de sexe puis de dire
que c'est votre première relation
sexuelle ça peut prêter à taux déroulé
ton condom trop vite on y croit repos
demande si elle aime ce type et cup
j'espère que au moins par la fiction on
va commencer à ressembler un peu plus
salariés et notre série enfin ça c'est
la meilleure série mandat n'ont plus
revu
non j'ai pris tous un très bon et puis
achats veut dire quoi par le ph de la
mine sous le crayon à celle hugues
aufray pascal hugo 2 c c'est dimitri
pascal hugo dimitris parce que tu as
départ un peu fly pan de sa peine pour
chantal non
ça s'appelle comment j'ai 300 au quai
alexandra ça la mode
marilou deborah pascal gauthier comme un
peu pascal non non c'est bon t'es le
seul parce que je m'étais accardi avant
moi ma marcheurs alexandre eck équitable
à cardy est telle que si ça cardy
c'est noté qu'au final à quatre écoles
secondaires viennent très cardinal
surnom qui est à ma tante à matane
ces fuites ont la pêche une faute fut
des fois pourquoi mais php h
hugo mais toi tu m'as pas fait appel
jusqu'au péage
je m'appelle foot ma belle pole ok
placebo fut moi j'avais beaucoup les
surnoms je trouve que ça ça me parle
d'un lien affectif institutrice camp que
les jantes appelle la même chose que tu
t'appelles à quelques coups de l'an
sûrement en mousse télé par exemple
c'est un lien affectif liste des pilotes
des frais matelas pour chiens
bush ouais je sortais avec un petit gork
les allégories pour je vous parle mon
avis tu me fais quand même pas aux
chochottes la peau mais pourquoi
l'appeler comme ça il était méchant
vraiment oui mais c'était chez nous on
avait tous des surnoms n'y a personne
qui s'appelait son vrai nom s'était
vraiment à qui va sortir la chine n'a
plus l'appui rapide puis quand je
sortais avec un petit la qualité pour
agir de la casca motion c'était un des
maires semaine sept pilotes demers
il ya des petites choses comme ce nom il
m'a piemme moi moi je devenais madame
chien avec chuck ben medjadji présentait
pas nommé mais moi mes frasques pamif
rasta comme un duo tissée serrée tu sais
pas ce que souhaitent y avait comme le
même âge qui espérait que ça soit un
troisième go le cari puis on commet
étaient déçus que du bon cependant moi
je t'ai barben on était dans une famille
on était huit clos c'est ma mère était
fatigué quand on a eu le jeu tout comme
celle de trondheim
extraits comme ça au plus fort la poche
si on avait même une de mes sens qui
était très très sensible puis à tout les
soirs auspices tech qui allait la faire
pleurer que l'once a envoyé mes potes
mais en même temps ça me développe entre
partie du tableau est là du stade à
l'humour qu'on pensait drôle mais c'est
un humour qui penseraient aujourd'hui
parlant de ce jeu là je voulais parler
de ses tantes aucun qui ont mentionné
guy a lepage
parce que il ya quelque chose dans la
trajectoire de carrière de de guillot
qui me fascine pis il ya un petit peu
les choses en temps trajectoire à toi
dans un bleu qui examine attend demain
dans une galaxie
ceux en qui il y avait un espèce de dix
jours doit y en a fait beaucoup aussi en
avant dans une galaxie mais un espèce de
folie de folie crb aux pilleurs qui
comme un qui s'appelle lui qui fait le
quittant taiwan en ce moment là bruno
blanchet qui est excellent mais jetez
pas votre sèchement genre d'affaires
d'humour un peu absurde d'un genre de
jeunes rebelles qui décide de faire leur
truc avec un dédain peu d'impro une mort
absurde pis puis on dirait que je le
retrouve plus pantoute aujourd'hui ce
genre de ce genre de je-m'en-foutisme je
fais ma propre affaire on dirait
qu'après ce farceur n'a rien su des
activités le dégoûte la télé tu as
l'impression de regarder un moule de
biscuits épisode après épisode après
épisode après épisode qui fit dans un
moule il avec un cadre vraiment précis
qui des thèmes qu'on aborde au pis je te
dirais que c'est marc labrèche qui est
le plus représenté 1 200 meilleurs
exemples de soho et le meilleur de ce
qu'il fait encore mal mais même même lui
il sait comme dircom tourner dans wii
avec avec la le cours actuel puis
curieuse de savoir si c'était comme un
mets ton dans une galaxie cette espèce
de vibe os qui vous faisiez carrément
qu'est-ce que tu es dans une galaxie
près de chez vous puis même titre qu est
ce qui se crée autour c'est beaucoup des
gens qui sortaient de l'impro point ses
fils l'impro step lutter portes sont
ouvertes plus ça devient intéressant
puis plus tape sur diderot parce que
j'ai encore beaucoup cette énergie
lhomond que j'amène à la radio mais ça
finit toujours par un regarde mais on
dirait que tu as raison c'est tout un
peu ce que tu l'oise habitude vu arriver
ce changement lui parce que mettons
j'étais le étaient arrivés un peu à la
fin de ce cette mouvance le méta tu te
tue ce disparaître un peu cette espèce
de laisser-aller de foule de folie dans
les médias traditionnels moi je me
demande si le fait de sortir une théorie
j'ai pas réfléchi du tout mais je me
demande si on prend par l'ensemble je me
demande si l'arrivée d'un espèce du mot
un peu plus formaté qui sortait de
l'école nationale de l'humour quand on
s'est mis à vouloir encadrer les mots
puis un le sortir comme une technique
je me demande c'est paulo que ça ne pas
tuer un peu parce que c'est encore des
denis drolet qui mêle ont comparé ce
sera quelque chose de plus théâtral a dû
gauvreau et tout ça mais pipi lui ment
risque est sorti est très très solide at
t y est pas sorti beaucoup de groupes
biotech les appendices qui ont continué
à faire de l'humour plus éclatée sur des
médias traditionnels c'est pour sauver
oui c'est à télé-québec aux autres les
appendices paraît mieux un show assez
longtemps mais c'est vrai qu'on dirait
qu'on s'est tous intellectualiser un peu
trop en humeau j'ai l'impression puis ça
ça comme réduit le terrain de jeu mais
je pense pas que tu es en écumant
déroule parce qu'on peut plus rien d
epuis le ya trop de politiques et
carrick je pense pas que c'est ça du
tout du tout c'est que l'imagination
andrex assez restreint ça c'est
resterait dans steam
moi je pense pas en fait mais je me pose
la question quand même est-ce que tu
penses que rbs pourrait exister
aujourd'hui puis avoir le même succès je
pense que oui mais je pense que oui mais
en même temps à barouette dire tellement
on ya tellement du mans reste maintenant
à l'humour est tellement partout les
humoristes sont rendus animateur de télé
aussi
c'est bien correct tout le monde est
capable de faire de tout mais mais ne
pourrait pas avec ce genre du moulleau
ces sources à penserai plus le même
je m'enferme au sénat catherine j'ai
toujours pas ce qu'est ce que j'ai dit
oui puis même si j'ai posé à huy
nous écrivait selon des critères y mange
tellement game jeu totalement et à ce
que je disais combien imagine ce qui en
fait un terrain commun qui ont pas ça
juste parce qu'un patron des clips qui
ressortent maintenant c'est sûr pourquoi
ans concentrons nous sur ce qu'on veut
vraiment pointé du doigt ou un sachet
mais oui mais c'est une en même temps
ceux qui ont chevauché les deux époques
là ça se dispute sur une conscience
collective est en train de se faire
c'est bien correct mais on peut pas et
passer tout ce qui avait l'an passé dit
il voulait même réécrit des voulait
enlever des épisodes de la petite vie un
moment donné ou un épisode non perso
dans stand up ça a été le témoin de deux
contrats versées aux six mètres en
raison de ces tristes que c'est en train
de cette espèce de sky is the limit
peut-être aussi que l'argent s'est mêlé
beaucoup beaucoup de la création c'est
même dans une galaxie près de chez vous
nous ont improvisé des saints ne se
reverrait plus dans le sentier même
jusqu'à retourner passer de la série au
cinéma de ok on peut plus il ya plus
l'espèce de petites dix minutes de grâce
qu'on peut gêner pour faire la scène un
peu ennuyeuse un parent ne sommes pas
décrochés lors on peut plus un fait
peut-être que ça c'est devenu une trouée
business en même temps j'ai l'impression
que peut-être que cette liberté là on la
retrouve ailleurs tim et on l'a
maintenant jeter quand je regarde les
sketches où l'été les vidéos qui mettent
en avant nous celui festif et voyons
donc à penser oui donc bien phu pilote a
éclaté peut-être que c'est le genre de
truc qu'on verrait plus à télévision
mais continue nouvelle plateforme mais
je trouve ça très ce qui est tout seul
quand même c'est parce que l'humour est
devenu très tout ça c'est ma business
humain c'est le fun les j'ai
l'impression que on avait la reprise des
gagne de cégep en aval à un peu
la prolonge l'adolescence et se mettant
le feeling que j'avais puis ben je le
savais pas à ce moment là parce que je
n'ai pas encore au cégep mais le feeling
que j'avais en gardant dans une galaxie
près de chez vous ça ressemblait
énormément au feeling que j'avais quand
j'allais les vendredis à la ligue
universitaire d'improvisation au peps de
l'université laval puis de juste faire
une gang d'amis qui s'élance le chat du
café des poètes cégep garneau le tchèque
sur le puits kitsch on est vraiment la
génération qui est une religion prêchée
je me souviens y avait radio à faible
das d'une galaxie c'était vraiment non
négociable et les simpsons mettons très
trop d'émissions dites et non négociable
mais c'est ce qu'il y avait une feuille
avait une folie puis sa part est ce que
en fait je peux commencer poser ces
questions est ce que est ce que vous
saviez ce que vous faisiez vous aviez
l'impression de faire n'importe quoi on
le savait pas vraiment au début je
comprends les pôles
quand j'ai quand j'ai créé ma sage trip
là dessus parce que c'était vraiment
comme une secte c'est moche harvey la
deuxième année pis pour moi je pensais
pas que ça allait être à ce point là
parce que j'avais l'impression que
c'était la gagne d'impro qui avait
décidé qu'ils avaient une subvention et
gary filles disent tout l'espace cousin
james cameron film exactement qui n'ont
pas su plateau tout le monde petit même
l'âge unique faisait accessoires qui
avait petit accessoire l'observer à
écouter capoter de venir nous présenter
qu'est-ce qui avait bricolé la veille
avait vraiment un esprit total depuis on
rentre vite dans cette secte là parce
que justement le midi notre faune ce qui
nous passait le dernier épisode qu'on
avait enregistrées qu'on avait pas vu
qu'on voyait avant tout le monde dont
s'assoyait to take new holland jeu puis
on saute ou très peu on tripait nous
mêmes sur un énorme service
vous savez vous où ça on savait que non
mais on savait que nous autres on
tripait parce que ça faisait partie de
notre univers mais on savait pas que ça
perdurer dans le temps puisque qui
auraient des deux guides et les deux
surprises de succès que ça le 8 est-ce
qu'ils étaient surpris de quel point
justement sa remarque une génération
oui j'ai été surprise en tout cas de
voir à quel point ça existe encore et
encore
page internet qui est bien entretenu il
ya eu en tout à fait puis on me traite
un espèce de salon comme un salon de
l'érotisme mais un salon de dans une
guerre d'opinion way une convention où
les gens font des coussins font des
costumes et des hippies vente des
produits dérivés dans une galaxie
c'est jusqu'à quatre saisons selon parce
que je pense que claude était tanné
klout depuis pierre-yves six autres qui
écrivait fait qu santé mais des trucs là
je souhaite qu'à cette nation est
peut-être plus je sais pas ce qu'ils
dormaient tout le temps c'est pour tout
ça soit lui c'est vrai comme en
seine-saint-denis où bob dormait en
truquant perdre a dit dépêchez vous
n'êtes pas chez vous parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'armé mais je n'ai pas la
foi il était juste formidable mais puis
après ça on a fait le film pour que
peut-être pour ça qu'on arrêtait nom de
fait le film après un jeu super vilain
il y en aurait un autre prince oui oui
oui on attend on attend que claude et
finisseur et bromont attend que les
autres projets sept ans mais c'est sûr
que la coved mais le fumier presque
terminé d'écrire
j'irai chez des jeux les aventures les
péripéties on ne pense pas que quelqu'un
meure pour se dépêcher
on frôle les doigts le scénario non non
non non mais des fois ils nous appellent
puis nous dit des petits des petits et
dave prowse du processeur et bâloise qui
écoute ça a été tellement riche l'eau
oieau notamment de bonnes questions de
quitter la terre
la texture homogène
oui oui mais en même temps c'est un peu
comme au même titre qu'un rb on dirait
qu'ils ont fait ils sont venus avec les
chaussettes et est une bonne idée de
foot il s est mort et des affaires un
moment donné j'ai dit mettons steve
carell pour faire des épisodes qui dit
la magistrate eu le crâne que vous avez
pas nous non parce que ne serait-ce que
juste pour nous un cadeau à nous de
pouvoir retravailler ensemble on va être
content c'est même s'il a juste trente
personnes soit mais entre nous je
rencontrais c'est ce petit maintenant
encore une fois le même temps que s'est
pas fait mais tant que c'est pas le gros
succès oui je le regarde avec sympathie
mis fin à sa carrière
un matin j'écoute est un passage à dieu
merci je me dis c'est une bonne émission
messam alliés même si quelques passages
la fois que la fois que j'avais
peut-être le premier qui parle en
anglais
oui ah ouais ouais ça ce je pense plus
que ça fonctionne réseau mais les
recettes pour personal finance apporte
pas une seule je pense qu'une personne a
le droit à un concept si on a fait
d'attendre je vois la même chose sans
raison est-ce que tu as oui c'était un
peu les cours d'eau sont quand même des
recettes tempête qui l'attend ne juge
pas l'idée c'est d'avoir déjà sous
l'influencé qu'il y ait une évolution au
fur et à mesure du podcast 80 substances
actives et tuent des gens genre que vous
auriez dit oh mon dieu il acceptera
jamais atteinte en guyane yatuu des gens
escaladent après je jeûne on est maudit
n'en jetez plus du monde des peuples du
monde musique pop du monde qui se sont
fiers de dire qu'on sera à quai aux
quais vote auquel la biotech jeu
en fait elle a d'autres étaient pas
négociables une leçon thalys ou pas de
caspian repris mathis n'est pas obligé
et ouais non c'était il ya eu des bons
malras par exemple d'un sur quatre
le projet est un peu y est fini car
j'étais vraiment difficile nous c'est
nous qui le produit ok c'est vraiment
difficile de vendre de la publicité
dessus parce que moi parce que personne
et parce que la personne veut s'associer
encore ça se fait qu'on l'a finie mais
il ya eu des bons moments d'amour qui
tombait complément buzz est un meuble et
lust et finit à la mise en place et le
temps d'un jeu barça a tranquillement
moi j'avais vu celui-là je pense qu'à
adamou qui a fait caca dans la rue
l'autre aurait bien m'a dit que ça
l'affairé n'avait pas vu à temps par web
spécialement traitement will you prix ni
parce que les toilettes étaient fermés
vita dans un festival
excuse moi d'amour que cette marche qui
a enlevé la bouche d'égout fils est pas
un chef mais c'est ça c'était le pas de
casque mi-août à 12% je l'avais vue puis
mis à raconter justement quelqu'un votre
caca dans sa douche alors qu'ils étaient
au séminaire puis ont cherché pendant
des semaines ce qui le faisait de kaka
temps de jeter comme devenu un
personnage mythique ça ça commençait
tout des bonnes histoires de merde des
bonnes choses comme ça qui est à nos
amis qui avaient poussé dans un chemin
d'un rush sur la wii mais ce qui se
passe quand tu puisses na heireann john
lennon c'est que ça sentait dans le
vestiaire au complet y ont fermé sur ne
puis on avait nos potes qui avait
prenant des leçons et et aux primaires
qui était celle en cours de natation en
voyons besoin de votre vie natation fait
mousser la vie natation la vie des
sports d'équipés de sport style très
particulier c'est sur les affaires que
j'ai que j'ai dit que j'ai fait
ce qui ressortira aujourd'hui je serais
pas fier mais je serais pas ici je peux
aussi dire avait quand même beaucoup de
certitudes que beaucoup de monde c'est
le cas dans l'intimité que des amis puis
dans un vestiaire de sport ses pochettes
en crise mais thomas granier divers non
non non cette fana que je dois manquer
ces matchs présenter aux primaires oui
notre coach y avait un système de
conséquence même temps on faisait des
coûts qu'elle avait une conséquence
avait des conséquences nouveau un hacker
qu'au niveau 2 la conséquence est plus
élevée cette inconséquence niveau troupe
la seule fois qu'ils avaient une
conséquence niveau où trouve t la fois
volailles avait fait pipi sous les
roches sono il a fallu qu'ils ferment le
vestiaire mais on est tellement sonné
c'était genre comme tout le monde des
rallyes great gig et sa place et on
s'aime et on tinto qui lui c'est notre
coach du du prix martin john lennon
entre autres primates avec les autres
couches puis une des conséquences de la
conséquence numéro 3 était d'aller
étudier à tous les coaches que tu avais
fait et puis il fallut cas elle voit
qu'ils ont tous ses bons débuts lancé
celui qui cote lille 25 4 épis est
obligé de te dire que j'ai fais pipi
sous les roches sont excusés tient plus
quelqu'un qui savait même pas être obtus
milliers insensiblement cinq personnes
pour le reste de ta vie soit identifié
comme le tigre que personnel
ben si c'était l'espoir de piste mais cb
n'est pas on dirait que je connais bien
je vois le genre il en fait autant sur
le genre h dominique ce truc comme ça
mais on se moque des gosses a atteint un
niveau d'exigence que des jeunes dieux
en équipe de sport ses cadres pensent eu
quelque chose acquise endorphines ou
quelque chose qui est directement liée
au cerveau il ya beaucoup d'émotion et
beaucoup pis moi je suis le premier à me
être plié les gaules concours de celui
qui pisse le plus loin celui qui va être
le plus cave
ah oui et puis ça canarde d'unités en
fait c'est comme ça c'est comme un peu
ribas est négatif mais en même temps ça
crée les licenciés des liens ca sud
piteux comme un espèce de d'esprit mais
c'est pas un moment précisément la
masculine la masculinité toxiques c'est
pas prendre précisément celui de qom
avoir viscéralement le besoin de prouver
aux autres vracs études à la cuisse le
dit de prouver qu'ils puissent eux mais
c'est probablement une fabrication
sociale complète
il ya un aspect aussi primitif dans le
truc mais je suis vraiment loin de moi
l'idée d'être un biologiste sur un
expert en je pense que je serai primitif
que le premier homme à pisser sur le feu
le feu mais de démontrer sa surface
assumer en faisant quelque chose
différent d'irrévérencieux car moins
acquis sans crise puis l'autre pour
gagner son approbation votre limite et
sa fille
j'ai le feeling que s'apportent don't be
c'est sûr que là où la grande majorité
sur la construction sociale dans
masculinité de mardi il ya quelque chose
dans l'air du temps aussi début 2000 qui
était un peu malsain dans le podor je te
confirme ben avancer parce qu'à l'époque
on était justement le à dos le prix ados
adorent et le tipi c'était vraiment
normal de tenir des petits pains des
propos dégradants de titres nous imitent
financera le on les traitait tipi
c'était bien je pas l'impression que tu
y déjeunent ou soirée se joue
aujourd'hui sont tous si collomb le
chemin qu'il était clos de l'époque où
si maintenant il ya encore un peu de
colonies t massa 7e oui c'est plus que
non mais c'est très intéressant comme
comme théorie de l'espèce de faire
partie du groupe fait cesser son compte
c'est sûr que la grande majorité c'est
une construction sociale mais aussi
parce que je pense qu'il ya cette
dynamique là
un des jeunes garçons qui est un peu un
peu un pack le fameux ce qu'ils disent
le tilt causse intellectuelle il désigne
le nombre de personnes des gones en
groupe il y aurait suffit qu'à une fille
pas loin pour qu'il fallait lever tous
ceux de m ont dit qu il est devenu
quasiment plus qu'avant on voulait
montrer qu'on était encore plus que moi
je voulais montrer que j'ai rapidement
compris que le pouvoir était du côté des
garçons fait que je voulais montrer que
je n'ai une la gagne c'est que je gagne
de parler de sexe de guînes des coachs
des wise pour essayer de m'élever aura
deux garçons pas je croyais que les
avantages et l autre sens effectivement
à ce que tu sens peas et ce même si
extrêmement malsain ce soit les lélés
raisonnement qu'on se portait mais
effectivement j'ai le feeling que tu dis
que tu mets le doigt dessus mais ce
n'est pas parce que des gens qui ont pas
eu cette réflexion l'autre c'est beau
parce que vous autres vous êtes capable
je pense que c'est votre génération vous
êtes capable de reconnaître que c'est
toxique qui s est jamais oui mais au
fait de notre avis aux amis chaque jour
je remercie le ciel nous parle encore
parce que ces absences
exact mais il ya quand même plein de
gens qui ont passé tout droit puis qui
sont têtus parlent des gens de ma
génération qui le font mais voyons dans
tout et on essaie toujours été de même
puis qui ont bossé tout droit pour
arriver à l'un l'espèce de conscience et
que d'autres se trouve que ça vaut bien
trop vite
les autres se trouvent que c'est exagéré
de vouloir mettre de diversité c'est au
site est aussi très apprécié on était
des enfants des ados pythie jamais on
s'est fait taper ses doigts vraiment et
par aucune autorité de je sais pas s'ils
l'ont vue probablement qu'ils l'ont vu
quelqu'un qui a été toléré parce qu'ils
avaient fait la même chose qu'un étage
est arrivé le téléthon je te raconter
aux primaires l'école secondaire légaux
pluvieux dit elle même puis on les
voyait comme des idoles un plus vous
êtes encore pire on reproduisait ap les
mêmes partout tout le temps ses pieds
puis même et y est il ya eu des coachs
chic et adoré par le même le décollage
on veut limiter ça c'est ça qu'on
connaît et pis c'est mou c'est vraiment
temouchent passer dessus du sport études
cij passé derrière tu sais déjà
c'est comme une toune urgence eu
beaucoup notre réflexion sur m'étais je
passais ses sorties du milieu du support
de l'équipe des sports vraiment soudé
tout le temps à 100 le tipi à j'ai
arrêté j'ai arrêté dans le fond la
natation après ce qu'on assène capital
étudiants en musique au cégep c'est là
que je passe d'une guigne des sportifs
en gagne d'artistes l'autize jours
l'allemagne puis mouche penser comment
qu'on se parle et c'est la manière
normale
la normale se rendent dans la cale plus
vulgaire jugé aucun sens sinon me
regarde tout sexy toile et qu'elle
prenne semaine afin ouais ok je m'ajuste
si oui un même personne non mais je sais
mais moi la radio je travaille avec des
go puis je reviens maison puis monde
jeune femme aurions tout sa croissance
et une coach est déjà moins ça
m'influence
non mais c'est sûr ces sottises et ses 4
sort de cette espèce de bulle qui
ferment et enjoint de sport du fait
qu'ils n'ont c'est pas comme ça qu'ils
m'ont interagissent normalement le x tu
respectes un peu les autres puis faut
faire attention mais c'est beau c'est ce
qui fait que tottenham bi aujourd'hui
des knicks est une référence dans
l'optique de donner rapidement des
projets mais est ce que tu veux tu
considères que tu vas te tendre et
prochainement la radio non j'espère que
non j'espère que non mais je sais que je
suis gosse amitié avec l'époque et
d'aujourd'hui tient dès cette année là
parce que les gens qui arrivent dans un
projet prévoyant ça marche on garde sont
bonnes ça marche
oui mais dans quatre jours ça va faire
deux ans et ça va faire 20 fois qu'on
voudra mais ma femme et moi il faut
changer mais non je pense que ça va être
mon chant du cygne la radio j'aimerais
ça oui c'est ça que je leur ai dit mon
j'aimerais sauf à ça jusqu'à la fin de
ma carrière
à moins que j'avais d'ailleurs mais
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup la radio j'aime
ce contact est ce que tu aimes tant que
seule une gemme l'improvisé
sinon j'aime le caiap a aucun médium ou
tout sens aussi près du public qu'à la
radio c'est drôle ça phénomène
d'attachement l'otage est passé d'une
station à l'autre le l'année passée
lorsque j'ai perdu
lyon décidé de sacrés l'équipe du matin
dehors puis il ya plein plein de gens
qui m'ont suivi parce que ya cette
proximité lot était tellement écouté
vraiment app store qui ont changé ce qui
me déçoit tous des menteurs mais je
pense que je pense que oui parce que tu
as vraiment une proximité avec les gens
qui ne veut pas la radio tête ou plutôt
raconter comme pas deux car ça tout les
jours le beau raconter juste on peut pas
trop pauvre prenant qu'on parle qu'on
parle de la coved non-stop les gens
veulent pas vraiment l'impression de te
connais et ils connaissent le nom tons
chauds ils connaissent à quel âge tu as
perdu ta virginité connaître surtout mon
jeu pas de filtre une grande grande
proximité avec les résultats
quitte à proximité indirectes aussi
parce qu'on texte est écrit en privé oui
à tout ça matin moi ça m'a fait
réfléchir non écoute il ya des gens qui
me confient leur vie au complet j'aime
beaucoup
moi je connais bien week-end radio à
québec débuté puis je talent est souvent
aussi je voulais me faisait craquer le
matin au pied puis à québec du moins
week-end radio est un peu un ovni
c'est d'assouan avenue qui a tout raflé
technique est devenu numéro 1 exact
c'est parce que c'est beaucoup de la
radio d'opinion au québec exerce en fait
l'essai de la musique mais c'est cette
faune et puis si ces postes à ma charge
tout ce qui ce qui était vraiment qu'au
québec et esca montréal du som by blood
c'est la même chose
et puis moi je trouve ça tellement
rafraîchissant parce que j'ai passé
justement de grosses institutions
multimillionnaire de hockey pour parler
de tel show de radio parce que c'est une
zone qui produisons pour parle de talent
émission tv pour tous reçoivent les
occupations de passer aux autres ils
sceptre m ça finit par être très
convergent impie aussi qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à montréal
c'est tout le monde se sont mis à faire
de la radio de la même façon
alors que week-end moi j'ai l'impression
que ça va être notre force c'est qu'on
fait de la radio comme disposé hier 20
ans ont fait de la radio parce qu on
aime la radio en fait de la radio pour
l'amuser c'est pas vrai que les autres
radios sont vraiment aux mondiaux à 8
heures on n'est pas nouvelle encore les
autres stations sont rendus aux
nouvelles cause des péchés d'autres
notre nouvelle des fois sa part à 8
heures et 10 passes que s'est passé
quelque chose du doute qui nous ont
appelés puis on a décidé de trouver son
iphone il parle et puis vous avez 7
malléabilité oui moi je sais oui
monsieur c'est pas de multinationales
ces deux freins deux jumeaux qui ont
décidé qu'ils trient pas sa radio puis
leur père avait une compagnie de
biscuits parfait papa tu ne saches
entretien pose en radio mais qu'ayant
fait que sont el matri pincer gollop qui
s'est vraiment des cds patron jeunes moi
je croise les jeunes travaillent pologne
parce que longtemps pandémie mais on est
tout de même plancher il n'y a pas cette
espèce de perrache de hiérarchie des
noms les ventes à bien des ventes d'app
à droite est simple il faut tout contact
les promos à 20 puis c'est qu'il ya
quelque chose de très organique qui a
que je pense que cette espèce de
s'insulter loupé cette authenticité
l'allégeant le sable c'est pas vrai que
parce que tu veux dire un char c'est ce
fait c'est un chant tati juste l'école
écurie de concours ou tentatives bol
puis on est vraiment très grande
proximité justement de si je sais pas
mais si katie holmes est à nous a
appelés bleus deux jours qui a rappelle
vont se rappeler que son fils s'appelle
sauf si on se rappelle que tu as une
dette
comment ça a été il ya vraiment quelque
chose de très cool avec cette radio mais
j'y crois beaucoup
g à venise ta main c'est vraiment le mot
la radio j'ai complètement arrêté de
consommer de la radio qu'un j'ai arrêté
de me déplacer
oui que j'ai arrêté d'aller à
l'université parce qu'il accepta québec
yolande leur servage c'était quand même
un bon accès dans le trafic c'était un
bon gars entre cinq minutes de me rendre
à l'université fait que j'avais je
développais cette relation avec moi
j'écoutais choix 100.9 à québec pitié
c'est l'espèce de la station rock de
choix les ai pas d'opinion c'était juste
du rock puis on a vu qu'ils étaient là
dessus un budget
fait que moi j'écoutais ce pied après ce
ça s'est transformé 1
c'est vraiment devenu le podcast pour
moi la suite
ouais de ma relation que j'avais j'ai
entraîné avec l'animateur qui en lofts
et à qui je peux plus vraiment paniers
bio en live ou exemplaires mais je peux
plus remplir des menteurs que j'écoutais
of fate le quai ce qui me reste c'est un
animateur de podcasts que je peux pas
nier et quand je veux le panier tué
parce que l'autre cette relation là
aussi mais je peux comprendre que met-on
si nous on faisait du live le si on
construit mais enlève le podcast ça
serait le fun d'avoir deux autres
reprises iresa je ne pense pas que ça va
être sur la suite des podcasts pas
franchement le premier podcast live qui
va se passer je vous en servez de la
radio web la radio pirate de discussions
mais il ya des gens qui font cela il y
en a pas beaucoup de fois mon fils y ait
beaucoup sur pink sweets winch pied lui
comprend pluie consomme pas de radio du
tout du tout puis comprends pas pourquoi
notre émission de radio et pas diffuser
leurs parce que le bassin énorme de gens
puisque et avec la pandémie aussi avec
le télétravail est de plus en plus de
gens qui nous écoutent sur les
hauts-parleurs intelligent fait là il
garde cette espèce de parce que la radio
c'est beaucoup avec la routine c'est ok
je sais que je me maquille pendant ce
segment alors je sais que rendu au quiz
je suppose aidé dans mon auto et que ça
reste un espèce de balises pour le temps
puis consommées l'info aussi où est-ce
que tu prends ton info tout je te revois
de ses nouvelles ben je regarde
rapidement les nouvelles je consomme
aussi tout abonné sur facebook est
abonné à des sources crédibles de
l'internet ont fait que comme mon fils
jamie nouvelle sinon les nouvelles ton
plus macro j'écoute de delhi le
intéresse le podcast de new york times
mais une nouvelle ici fecteau pas besoin
d'avoir à charge mais non mais pis juste
ça c'est vrai que maintenant que plus
les gens consomment moins de radiologues
mais pourtant un disque
la radio ce programme le dernier médium
qui va surveiller ça a tout l'air dé de
l'aide d'internet est plus inquiète pour
la radio pourquoi pas de mon vivant
après ça vous autres vous entrez mais
non je peins non moi je pense que c'est
encore c'est encore bien vive comme
quest que je serais inquiet si ça
devient trop justement quand ça devient
trop quelque chose de formater puis
d'une publicité mais on ne veut plus de
publicité athée disposeraient que ça va
devenir payant pour les commanditaires
parce que toutes les radios sur les
médias puis tu le bien de tentes aux cdd
mais la traque des boîtes des nôtres qui
possède 85 stations de radio avec sa
voix pas de télé puis c'est une boîte
qui fait tout seul puis là dedans et ont
beaucoup de stars fait un bruit créé de
la job beaucoup baissé on ne reproche au
sol on a repris 7
on aurait presque sans énormément à des
gros ampli comme kébé cap sow met tout
le monde essaie d'imiter ce qu'on essaie
de faire sauter que c'est chez certaines
autres mon ancien employeur
celui qui fonde c'est mon chèque au bout
du compte et à toronto et aucune idée
chi chi chi flop est un chef de trop on
à l'absolu c'est sûr que s'est désuni
ccc déshumidificateur c'est ça le mook
ce serait les idées humanistes quelqu'un
d'autre veut 0 1 dans sa demi qu'on
accole dow nicole juin sa famille que
j'ai le droit de poser des questions
oui c'était mieux vivre dans l'ombre
parce que nicole t le manipulateur de
[ __ ] en [ __ ] et les gens parler puisque
gargariser de leurs de leurs idées leurs
théories je t'aime ça ouais moi en fait
mme en fait je pense que chi plus
confortable même dans l'ombre
j'aime j'aime vraiment ce à être
derrière mais python puis d'après toi là
dans le deux heures de débat la terrasse
yong et file au scav à garden dix
minutes tout gadret lequel quels sujets
dont on a parlé du cas d'école pas vrai
ses côtés d'al qaîda pris dans ma note
je donne ni comme c'est le cas au québec
qui écoutait plus un podcast parce qu'il
fait parce qu en fait quatre par jour
l'été fait trop amplement je dois être
au moins dans le top 5
probablement non mail toute la partie
sur la sexualité j'ai fait cher alain
moussu c'était son moment préféré c'est
le même je recherchais une conne changer
fait lancer trop x1 petits missiles non
mais non vous n'êtes pas prêt je
comprenne cols que ça t'intéresse parce
que on en parle peu
voilà qu il n'y a plus de ya plus
d'émissions qui traite de sexualité dont
un sexologue une fois de temps en temps
dans une émission de radio qui va dire
oui ça veut dire ce qui se passe chez le
couple
mais ça reste quand même un des derniers
tabous on dirait mais on est lancé on à
la ccîo pas de calais au studio 1 pas de
cas ce qu'ont produit qui s'appelle sexe
oral ses deux filles parlent de
sexualité
c'est vraiment beau non c'est bon dans
le temps c'est quoi il y avait tant de
joie indrindra pile le fruit qui donne
sexe c'est n 1 en deux comme on appelait
son look est ce qu'apple a tous nos
personnages au lady marianne québec qui
c'était une des expériences les plus
traumatisants troublant sa fille
s'appelle clémentine souci j'avais
perméable première manche n'est pas le
genre performa une fille qui fait de la
performance aquatique à qui sait comme
c'était un happening lester genre un peu
gingka mais comme si tu vaux d'agde qui
avait géré aussi de façon un peu plus
moderne moi je suis trop x puis
justement quand j'étais à aller dans un
bar de danseuses il y avait un goût
quitte à son enterrement du garçon puis
c'était ça le gros challenge de 6 était
capable de sera en outre orange était
capable et moi j'avais pas autant mais
mettons aucune des exemples qu'est-ce
que j'en ramène pas ce qui a mené à
terme
il ya un gars qui était atténue pin
était il y avait mis 10 à rendre à petit
autour de lui qui guettait comme il
était comme demain elvis et l'i way elle
avait scellé et a fait un trou dans sa
phase pilote tech 3 points 1 pile aa
signe à quatre pattes devant pleurs
fallait qu'il gueule il a eu l'air four
de gistel ans aranda une expérience
comme le mans folle après ça il était
comme issue est crissement d'un site où
trempent le fait que des paiements
d'étapes à deux cas cela j'étais un peu
chaud puis moment mon sur mer est floue
mais steyn des affaires les plus drôles
que j'ai vécu c'est très bizarre hein
tout cet univers le nom par les
tropiques un jeu sans parler des
catégories mais on y compte nous aurons
pris là dessus un monde qu il lui a fait
exprès tout est arrangé mais tu regardes
les catégories tu fais bien voyons donc
une moc dans notre souffle d'air une des
émissions d'aller voir le père de
primestar pis on voulait parler de
comment y avait réagi avec la victoire
in store de son fils mais lui était
propriétaire d'un village où les gens se
rendaient la fin de semaine pour se
déguiser en bébé et pour assouvir leurs
fantasmes avec une couche mais ça existe
c'est celle imaginée à oui non non c'est
clair mais tout ça pour dire que il y
avait il y avait un lacet quoi puis
c'était fort intéressant mais parce que
c'est le monde du tabou mais c'est le
monde du de l'humain aussi que c'est
kinetic qu'est ce qui se passe et tu
parce qu'il ya comment tu peux te rendre
aussi loin dans des fantasmes
comment tu veux tu peux être juste à
côté de tomber dans la normalité ou ce
qui maintenant j'imagine et n'est plus
et plus de catalogue de normes j'ai
sûrement la porte c'est vraiment la
chose qui est ces gros gros pourcentages
monde qui regarde ce lundi
on n'a pas jamais très loin de parler
aujourd'hui même je pense qu'on a parlé
deux trois fois sur des basses castes
130 lb on n'en parle pas on fait comme
s'ils n'existaient pas c'est tout le
sait vraiment c'est comme puis aussi on
n'a pas parce que c'est sensationnel
liste on se rappelle de troubles je me
rappelle la fille que son go il y avait
son père il y avait aidé à monter son
côté chaussures ça drilles sanaa qui te
compares et est contre nous montrer mais
on a passé ça on ajoute ces histoires
qui nous restent mais on n'y a plus
aucune plateforme on parle de sexualité
fois scène où tu sais moi j'aime bien
mieux je veux entendre parler de
sexualité tantrique je veux savoir
comment se fait que sting est capable de
faire l'amour pendant 12 ans il ya tout
quelqu'un pour me l'expliquer
contrepartie et coûterait au sexe oral
ah oui ça c'est plus elle parle de
chemise ans de découvrir sa sexualité
des différentes expériences puis
évidemment éventuellement c'est sûr que
les faits m'ont parlé de 6,39 points
du point de vue féminin wifi les filles
team à ton temps en temps il voir une
sexologue qui vient mais les filles sont
pas sexologue s'est juste dit non
factice est vraiment dans l'humour puis
dans la légèreté c'est bien dans les
expériences personnelles c'est vraiment
un crime ou jugée coûteuse crampes et
tellement drôle de défi sont bonnes
baptisé justement il ya dix ans qui a
fait ça avec une fille qui s'appelle
jouanny hockey celi récurrent c'est
toujours les défauts sont juste les deux
cpie parle c'est accompli
c'est vraiment le fun un enfant est une
sorte de bar de danseuses de l'écouter
c'est le piment lui a toujours su les
règles qu'il faut libérer ont laissé
passer un petit bain on n'a pas dépensé
encore mais il tresse double parce que
c'est a besoin il est de bon ton
anecdote est trop épais mais à mes 18
ans qui chante avec lui les embarquer
pineau de monter 18 à tous méditant moi
bien eu dans le fond mais ma première
expérience ever ou danseuses étaient à
ses 18 ans puis il ya aussi des bonnes
histoires de raconter mes amis 18 ans on
dans un bar c'est aux stars band et à
00h tu étais pas loin c'est ce pilot ya
mon frère puis 2 3 go qu'à minuit
m'avait pas dit ils me prennent kidnappe
il m'amène pis
une bande les yeux et mais dans un taxi
plus comme où est ce qu'on va peut-être
mes amis y avait ma blonde l époque
étaient dans le box à moi juste
disparaître qui est comme un peu ch rue
parce que il écopera m'ont pris mon
téléphone + moi j'ai dû garder plus on
arrive au lady marianne c'est que la bar
de danseuses à québec on arrivé là et
puis le genre important de m'asseoir
jeune fille qui vient me chercher tes
tout lien avec moi type la maman d'un
petit teaser up de plasma danse et puis
c'est moche je suis guitariste fait que
j'ai raison
quand même longtemps oui la classe m'a
bercé mes luttes à mener a fait ils
tombaient les angles longerait watching
taris 108 me rater le doubs actuellement
j'ai passé ma fait de 18 ans gratuit
je vous ai loupé el-assad a gratté la
bressaude cette fois c'est par une
danseuse de spi merci beaucoup merci moi
c'était vraiment intéressant vraiment
vraiment le fun merci merci colin merci
merci alors déçu le travail m